bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur les
dérives sectaires en milieu hospitalier
pour commencer leurs travaux les
sénateurs ont choisi d'auditionner Serge
blisco c'est le président de la milude
il leur a expliqué que la multiplication
des pseudothérapeutes devenait
inquiétante nous ne sommes pas contre
les nouvelles formes de médecine a-t-il
expliqué mais quand la santé des
patients est en danger et bien c'est à
nous de tirer la sonnette d'alarme je
vous propose donc tout de suite
d'écouter son audition en intégralité
bonne matinée à
tous
bien mesdames messieurs bonjour mes
chers
collègues donc nous procédons
aujourd'hui à à la première audition
notre commission
d'enquête sur l'influence des mouvements
à caractère sectaire dans le domaine de
la
santé la commission d'enquête a souhaité
que notre réunion d'aujourd'hui soit
ouverte au public et à la presse un
compte-rendu intégral en sera publié
avec le rapport son enregistrement vidéo
sera diffusé sur le site du
Sénat j'attire donc l'attention du
public ici présent il est tenu
d'assister à cette audition en silence
toute personne qui troublerait les
débats par exemple donnant des marques
d'approbation ou
d'approbation sera exclu sur le champ
j'en viens donc à notre réunion et c'est
tout naturellement que nous avons
souhaité commencer nos auditions par le
docteur Serge blisco président de la
milude Mission interministérielle de
vigilance et de lutte contre les v
sectaire depuis août dernier
après avoir été député de Paris et
vice-président du groupe d'études sur
les sectes à l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur blisco est accompagné par
Monsieur Hervé Machi magistrat
secrétaire général de la milude et
Monsieur Samir
kalalfaoui inspecteur principal des
affaires sanitaires et sociales et
conseiller au ple santé
d'amilude je rappelle donc à l'attention
de Monsieur blisco et ses collaborateurs
que chacun des groupes politiques du
Sénat
dispose d'un droit de tirage annuel qui
lui permet notamment de solliciter la
création d'une commission
d'enquête le bureau du Sénat a accepté
la demande du groupe RDSE d'utiliser ce
droit pour soulever la question de
l'influence des mouvements à caractère
sectaire dans le domaine de la santé
c'est sur cette base que notre
commission d'enquête s'est constitué le
3 octobre
dernier Monsieur Jacques
mzard auteur de la proposition de
résolution qui se trouve à l'origine de
la constitution de cette commission en
est donc le rapporteur un mot mes chers
collègues pour vous présenter la mie
Lude cet organisme a été institué auprès
du Premier ministre notamment pour
coordonner l'action préventive et
répressive des pouvoirs publics à
l'encontre des dérives sectaires mener
une action d'observation du phénomène
sectaire à travers ses agissements
attentatoires au droits de l'homme aux
libertés fondament
ou contraire aux lois et règlements
contribuer à la formation et
l'information des agents publics dans le
domaine de lutte contre les dérives
sectaaires informer le public sur les
risques liés aux dérives sectaires et
facilité la mise en œuvre d'action
d'aide aux victimes de dérive secteur la
Mivilude a été créé en
2002 à la suite de la Mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
sectes qui a pris elle-même la suite en
1998 de l'Observatoire interministériel
sur les sectes lui-même constitué en
1996 mes chers collègues il est
éclairant de souligner que la Mivilude
est une structure qui n'a pas
d'équivalent dans le monde à l'exception
peut-être du centre d'information et
d'avis sur les organisations sectaire
nuisiblebles euh créé en Belgique en
1998 je vais maintenant conformé
à la procédure applicable au commissions
d'enquête demander à Monsieur blisco
ainsi qu'à monsieur HERV mai et Samir
calfaoui de prêter serment je rappelle
pour la forme qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission sur les passies
des peines prévues aux articles
434- 13
434-1 434- 15 du code pénal monsieur
mieur Monsieur Serge
Bisco serement de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité lev de maain droite
et dit je jure je le jure Monsieur Hervé
Machi prêteèement de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levez la main
droite et dites je jure je jure monsieur
Samir calfaoui prêtez serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levez
la main droite et dites je le jure je le
jure monsieur le Président Brisco à la
suite de votre exposé introductif mon
collègue Jacques mzard rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête vous vous posera un
certain nombre de questions puis les
membres de la commission d'enquête vous
solliciteront à leur tour monsieur le
Président vous avez la parole merci mon
le président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est un honneur et et un
plaisir pour moi de m'exprimer
aujourd'hui devant la Haute Assemblée en
tant que président de laamivilude
fonction que j'occupe depuis 3 mois et
sur un thème choisi par votre commission
d'enquête parlementaire l'influence des
mouvements à caractère sectaire dans le
domaine de la santé vous avez rappelé ce
qui'est la Milu et son action monsieur
le Président je n'y reviens pas juste
pour dire qu'elle est composée d'une
quinzaine d'agents répartis en pôle de
compétences qui correspondent au champ
d'investigation d'intervention de la
mission santé enfant éducation sécurité
justice vie professionnelle et bien sûr
ses compétences techniques pôle
parlementaire et presse tous les agents
je le précise sont mis à disposition de
la mivilud par leur ministère d'origine
vous le savez la mivilud n'a pas
vocation à définir ce qu'est une secte
respectueux de toutes les croyances et
fidèle au principes de laïcité le
législateur s'est toujours refusé à
définir les notions de sectes ou de
religion afin de ne pas heurter les
libertés de conscience d'opinion de
religion garantie par les textes
fondamentaux de notre République pour
autant tout n'est pas permis au nom de
la liberté de conscience ou la liberté
de
religion en effet l'absence de
définition de la secte n'efface pas la
réalité de l'existence de victimes de
dérives de certains mouvement sectaire
la loi fixe donc des bornes qui
sanctionnent les abus de ses libertés
sous le contrôle du juge ainsi le
dispositif juridique français tout à
fait exceptionnel est à la fois
pragmatique et textuellement encadré
il vise à la prévention et à la
répression non des sectes en elles-même
mais des dérives secteures cette notion
de dérives secteur s'est progressivement
affiné par référence à des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires je
rappelle en particulier la loi du 12
juin 2001 réprimant l'abus de faiblesse
de personnes placées en état de
suggestion psychologique d loi Abou
Picard le décret du 28 novembre 2002 en
découle qui a institué l'amivilude et la
circulaire du Premier ministre du 27 mai
2005 relative à la lutte contre les
dérifes sectaires dans ce cas les
dérivfes sectaires peuvent être définis
comme des atteintes pouvant être porté
par tout groupe ou tout individu à
l'ordre public aux lois et aux
règlements aux libertés fondamental à la
sécurité ou à l'intégrité des personnes
par la mise en œuvre de techniques de
suggestion de pression de menaces ou par
des pratique favorisant l'emprise
mentale et privant les personnes d'une
partie de leur libre arbitre pour les à
commettre des actes dommageables pour
elle-même et pour la société cette
définition paraît simple et je le
rappelle nous ne interdisons de porter
quelques jugement de valeur que ce soit
sur les doctrines les théories ou les
croyances en tant que telles l'objet de
la milude et de dénoncer
systématiquement les dérives sectaires
et bien sûr de lutter contre elles avec
l'aide des pouvoirs publics alors pour
exercer cette mission de vigilance nous
appuyons notamment sur un certain nombre
de critères de dangerosité et dicté
d'ailleurs sur la base des travaux et de
plusieurs commissions d'enquête
parlementairire et sur notre propre
expérience qui vous avez bien voulu le
rappeler et maintenant a maintenant plus
de 15 ans parmi ces points qui nous
semblent importants parmi ces critères
la déstabilisation mentale le caractère
exorbitant des exigences financières
exorbitant qu'on retrouve très souvent
la rupture avec l'environnement
d'origine l'existence d'atteinte à
l'intégrité physique l'embrigadement des
enfants le discours antisocial les
trouble à l'ordre public l'importance
des démêlés judiciaires l'éventuel
détournement des circuits économiques
traditionnels les tentatives
d'infiltration des pouvoirs publics bien
sûr c'est sur ces critères un seul
critère ne suffit pas pour caractériser
l'existence d'un risque de dérive
secteire et tous les critères n'ont pas
la même valeur le premier critère est
sans doute toujours présent c'est la
déstabilisation mentale toujours présent
dans les cas de DF sectaire
l'observation que nous faisons du
paysage et du phénomène sectaire
aujourd'hui est la suivante si elles
existent toujours les dérives sectaires
dans les grands groupes religieux ou
prétendu tels comme la Scientologie ou
les Témoins de Jéhova ou dans les
communautés religieuses issues des
grandes religions traditionnelles et de
plus en plus fermées sont aujourd'hui
devenus nettement minoritaires par
rapport aux défes sectaires constatés
dans le domaine de la santé de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'éducation des
enfants parallèlement à ce changement du
champ d'intervention on assiste à un
morcellement du paysage sectaire où les
grands groupes organisés souvent de
taille internationale laissent
progressivement la place à une multitude
de petites structures parfois composées
de quelques personnes seulement morcelé
et dispersé sur l'ensemble du territoire
national en zone urbaine comme en zone
rurale le caractère isolé de ces
nouveaux gourous doit cependant être
nuancé par le fait que s'ils agissent
souvent seul ou dans une zone
géographique limitée il fonctionneent de
plus en plus en réseau organisé mettant
en œuvre les mêmes méthodes ou agissant
selon un mode d'intervention similaire
on peut parler d'atomisation du
phénomène sectaire en somme ce qui
caractérise la dérive sectaire
d'aujourd'hui c'est la notion d'emprise
mentale exercée sur une personne par une
autre peu importe le cadre sur lequel
s'effectue cette emprise et la nature
des activités suivies cette évolution
explique que l'on puisse parler de dérif
secteur même dans une relation entre
deux personnes entre deux individus cela
est particulièrement vrai dans le
domaine de la
santé je reconnais qu'il est à première
vue difficile d'imaginer des dérives
sectaires dans le domaine de la santé on
connaît un certain nombre de dérives
guérisseuses de certains groupes
religieux euh la laagapé thérapie de la
Communauté des Béatitudes ce dont le
livre noir du psychospirituel du CCMM
c'est une association de défense des
victimes rencontte avec précision on
voit aussi un son de dérive de pasteurs
déviants de quelques églises
évangéliques j'insiste bien sur quelques
églises évangéliques qui peuvent appeler
à la guérison de certains fidèles par la
prière à l'exclusion c'est sans doute là
le terme le plus important de tout
traitement médical conventionnel le
doctrine d'un autre grand groupe sur le
refus de la transfusion sanguine qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui est également
connu de tous et puis il y a aussi des
mouvements d'inspiration New Age qui
découragent le retour aux vaccination
sur surfant il est vrai sur certains
échecs de campagne récentes
malheureusement mais imaginez que la S
est un secteur protégé à l'abri de
tenerman parce qu'il est le secteur de
la santé réglementé encadré exercé par
des professionnels formé par un système
universitaire soumis à des règles
drologiques très strictes c'est
difficile de l'imaginer en réalité des
gardesfous existe mais ces règles sont
détournées par des pseudopraticiens qui
s'arrochent de titres farfelus
naturopathes psychopraticiens et cetera
faisant F des dernières réformes par
exemple encadrant le titre de
psychothérapeute et l'on se rappelle
qu'il était extrêmement difficile et
très long pour arriver à je dirais un
relatif consensus sur ce qu'on peut sur
ce qu'on peut appeler un
psychothérapeute dans ce pays ou
exploitant tout simplement l'acsence de
réglementation on a par exemple la
floraison aujourd'hui de centre de
bien-être ou d'invention de nouvelles
méthodes
pseudothérapeutiques ou bien alors
profitant de l'absence de contrôle et
donc on assiste à l'émergence d'un
supermarché pas d'autres termes de
pratiques de soin de méthodes de
guérison de technique de bien-être de
mieux-être de développement personnel
qui peuvent présenter un risque de
dérive sectaire et qui s'offre à une
clientè entre guillemets en demande
croissante quelques chiffres il existe
plus il existe plus de 400 pratiques non
conventionnel à Visé thérapeutique dans
notre jargon nous appelons ça les pncvt
pratique non conventionnelle à Visé
thérapeutique la mivilud constate
quotidiennement l'apparition de
nouvelles méthodes souvent d'ailleurs
très voisine d'une méthode ancienne
c'est un nouveau praticien qui fait sa
petite méthode à lui l'absence d'un
cadre légal clair favorise cette
prolifération qui peut s'accompagner
dans certains cas de la vente
d'appareils et de produits divers censé
apporter le bien-être ou la guérison on
dénombre aujourd'hui 1800 structure
d'enseignement de formation à risque
dans le domaine de la santé 1800 ça
couvre tout depuis des stages
incroyables de 3 jours d'une journée
voire des qui s'étalent sur plusieurs
sur plusieurs semaines ou mois des
séminaires des du soir qui forme ces
pseudopraticiens à côté de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de
pseudothérapeutes autoproclamés par
définition le nombre est difficilement
chiffrable car il n'apparaissent pas
souvent dans l'annuaire ou dans les
annuaires professionneles bien qu'il en
existe il y aurait environ et c'est une
estimation qui est déjà ancienne donc
elle doit être dépassée aujourd'hui
c'est une estimation du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins 3000 médecins
diplômés c'est un autre problème à
l'intérieur de la profession médicale en
lien avec la mouvance sectaire et dont
les méthodes nous inspirent la plus
grande méfiance
au total et c'est un chiffre qu'il faut
retenir les dérives secteures dans le
domaine de la santé représentent près de
25 % 1/4 de l'ensemble des signalements
reçus la mvilude en en 2011 nous avons
reçu quasiment 2400 signalements 600
j'arrondi les chiffres concernent le
domaine de la santé aussi bien organique
que psychologique c'est le premier
secteur sur lequel la Mivilude exerce sa
vigilance comme pour le phénomène
secteur en général le volet santé de ses
dérives concerne certes je l'ai dit
encore les pratiques des grands
mouvements strctur structurés de taille
internationale mais je le disais celle
de gourou de plus en plus isolé gourou
isolé plutôt qu'il faut savoir repérer
encore une fois une confusion peut avoir
lieu on peut je crois se méfier de
dérivve secteur de N a pas adéquation
parfaite entre ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les dérives secteures ce qu'on appelle
les dérif secteur est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler les dérif thérapeutique mais il
existe des interconnexions évidente
entre les
deux une dérive thérapeutique
s'apparente à une pratique non
conventionnelle à Visé thérapeutique qui
présente qui peut présenter un danger
pour les personnes ou peut prendre la
forme d'un dévoiement par des
pseudopraticiens non reconnus de pratiqu
médicales reconnu et éprouvé et
là-dessus nous avons un certain nombre
d'exemples qui montrent que l'on passe
insensiblement d'une ce que je pourrais
appeler d'une originalité d'une pratique
à une pratique nouvelle une pratique qui
peut être dangereuse une pratique qui
devient systématique et qui parfois
parfois mais pas toujours est en lien
avec une dérive sectaire c'est-à-dire un
phénomène d'emprise en particulier parce
que la di sectaire je le rappelle
sousentend la notion d'emprise mentale
exercée par une personne sur une autre
donc je le répète ici pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de de j'allais dire de de de
confusion ou de de contresens toute
dérive thérapeutique n'est pas forcément
sectaire mais il faut reconnaître que
dans ce domaine la maladie est une porte
d'entrée rêvée pour les mouvements à
caractère sectaire qui profitent de la
souffrance de l'inquiétude de l'angoisse
des malades et de leur famille pour
mieux exercer une emprise à leur égard
il y a donc pour nous un risque
supplémentaire de dérive secteur dans le
champ de la santé en raison de la
fragilité de la vulnérabilité des
personnes et de la multitude de
pratiques proposées parfois sans aucun
contrôle le danger résiste bien sûr
résist surtout dans les pratiques
alternatives qui aboutissent alternaat
au traitement dit conventionnel le terme
conventionnel a déjà petite connotation
péjorative dans ses dans leur bouche si
j'ose dire mais nous nous à la limite
nous sommes très désireux de ne pas
condamner toutes les pratiques dites
complémentaires mais de nous attaquer à
ce qui est pour nous est dangereux la
pratique alternative qui aboutisse par
l'emprise exercée par le
pseudothérapeute ou le gourou à
détourner le malade des traitements
conventionnels avec pour conséquence une
perte de chance de guérison voir un
risque vital nous avons dans le Guide
Santé des RF sectaire à plusieurs donner
plusieurs exemples évidemment en
camouflant les noms de De de ce type de
mésaventures gravissimes et c'est là que
on voit le poison sectaire s'instiller
et pour ceux qui plus anciens que moi
l'ami vilude ont depuis le début
commencé à caractériser ce qu'était
l'emprise sectaire et on voit toujours
le même phénomène la rupture avec la
famille ou l'entourage la famille qui
souhaite souvent le maintien du
traitement conventionnel des exigences
financières de plus en plus fortes de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
d'euros l'embrigadement dans un
processus sans fin ça aussi c'est une
dérive bien connue on participe à des
stages on va pas bien donc on dit que il
faut accentuer le traitement qu'il faut
faire une retraite un séminaire
notamment partir à l'étranger dans une
clinique spécialisée parce qu'en France
on n' pas le droit pour mieux
s'imprégner de la méthode suivie on
renvoie vers d'autres praticiens dé
viiant qui font partie du même réseau
chacun prend évidemment évidemment des
honoraires Exor habitant à ce sujet et
puis on a cette soumission à une
suggestion psychologique permanente qui
va en défin transformer la personne dans
sa vie de tous les jours et dans ses
rapports avec les autres et qui peut
aller jusqu'à des atteintes à son
intégrité physique ou sexuelle c'est
bien évidemment aussi l'occasion de
bonne fortune pour un certain nombre de
thérapeutes je n'évoque pas ici je le
dis clairement ce qu'on est convenu
d'appeler dans le code de la santé ou
dans à l'ordre des médecins les
médecines complémentaires souvent
prescrites d'ailleurs en lien avec un
traitement médical classique par une
équipe de professionnels reconnus et qui
est souvent une aide intéressante
notamment milieu hospitalier sur la
douleur sur mieux s'alimenter après un
traitement lourd pour le pour un cancer
par exemple qui en général se traduit
par on le sait par une perte de poids ou
une perte d'appétit donc on ne ici à
dénoncer à la misut que les pratiques
alternatives à un traitement médical
établi à reconnu qui dans un contexte
d'emprise mentale exercé par des
charlatans de la santé ou
malheureusement par des médecins
déviants peuvent aboutir à de véritables
drames humains dont nous recevons
quotidiennement des témoignages souvent
poignants alors comment expliquer
quelque part le l'engouement des
Français pour des pratiques
potentiellement dangereuses je crois
qu'à la rencontre d'une offre et d'une
demande la demande on le sait s'explique
par plusieurs facteurs la crainte des
traitements lourds et la recherche d'une
forme de médecine plus humanisé ou moins
technicisé la peur d'accidents médicaux
de maladies nosocomiales des effets
indésirables de certains traitements
c'est une peur tout à fait légitime une
certaine défiance il faut le dire aussi
vis-à-vis de l'industrie pharmaceutique
de ce point de vue une affaire récente
que je n'évoquerai que par périphhrase
mais que vous avez tous en tête qui est
aujourd'hui à l'instruction et fortement
médiatisé a accru cette défiance ces
derniers mois et ces dernières années on
s'en rend compte en consultant tous les
sites internet et puis je crois sur cet
arrière-fond la recherche d'un retour au
naturel à la vraie nature au bio bref au
médecine dou douce par opposition au
médecine dure le traitement le terme
étant en soit évocateur déjà d'un
jugement de valeur il y a une médecine
douce celle qui ne guérit pas par
rapport à une médecine douce une
médecine dure qui elle guérit mais qui
est effectivement parfois très difficile
à accepter pour un malade pour une
personne à qui on va on va proposer un
traitement ou imposer parfois un
traitement particulièrement lourd selon
l'EMS 75% des Français ont recours au
moins une fois un traitement
complémentaire encore une fois cela ne
nous choque pas qu Français sur 10 ont
recours habituellement à des médecines
alternative ou complémentaire ça c'est
plus inquiétant dont 60 % parmi les
malades du cancer il est bien évident
qu'on est actuellement dans une nouvelle
are de la médecine si j'ose dire où il y
a beaucoup de malades au long cours qui
vont aller revenir de l'hôpital avec des
traitements plus ou moins longs des
séquences des traitements et dans
l'intervalle je le reconnais volontiers
nous le savons tous euh la médecine
hospitalière ne s'occupe pas beaucoup de
ce qui se passe dans l'intervalle donc
c'est là que là il y a cet état de
fragilité des patients donc cette
demande moi je la reconnais comme
légitime nous la reconnaissons comme
légitime cette demande des patients mais
elle rencontre une offre qui elle est
beaucoup moins légitime c'est l'offre
des mouventss sectaires qui ont compris
en particulier ces dernières années
l'enjeu de cette mode est l'exploitation
qu'il pouvait tirer de la peur de la
maladie ils vont ainsi jouer sur les
deux tableaux la peur la détresse la
souffrance le désarroi des malades ou de
leur famille et vont proposer là je
devrais dire écrire là avec un grand tel
un grand là la solution miracle qui va
guérir toutes les maladies en respectant
bien sûr le malade en ne le faisant pas
souffrir en lui apportant une écoute
bien supérieure à celle qu'on peut
trouver dans un service d'hospitalier
alors je je reviens sur cette solution
miracle parce que pour nous quand on
garde ça de près c'est aussi un des
traits finalement de la de
l'imprégnation secteur dans le domaine
de la santé est-ce que on remarque très
souvent que la même méthode peut tout
guérir des maladies qui normalement
effectivement devrait aller dans un tel
ou tel service hospitalier ou même bien
on guérit la la sclérose en plaque le
cancer l'infection par le VIH l'hépatite
mais bien d'autres maladies lourdes et
longues et le diabète et cetera qui sont
effectivement des maladies qui qui sont
invalidantes et et parfois très graves
donc on est en face de de de de
médications de thérapeutiques qui sont
extrêmement
polyvalentes pluripotente on pourrait
dire et qui peuvent tout guérir de ce
point de vue c'est pour nous un indice
déjà de dangerosité et puis évidemment
les les pseudothérapeutes s'inspirent du
mode du retour à la nature aux vraies
valeurs à la vraie médecine basée aussi
sur l'épanouissement de soi ainsi la
santé les méthodes alternatives les
pratiques isoires de guérison sont
devenus un puissant et efficace vecteur
de recrutement des mouvements à
caractère sectaire souvenons-nous que
l'Ordre du Temple solaire c'est d'abord
des conférences sur la bonne nutrition
c'est d'abord sur la la médecine douce
d'ailleurs en plus j'allais dire euh euh
validé par le le fait que un des ses
principaux dirigeants qui est d'ailleurs
lui-même décédé dans les deux horribles
drames qui ont lieu dans le dans les
Alpes et dans le vercor était un médecin
bien connu le docteur Luc Jouret alors
face à cette déferante de méthode de
pratique de technique quelle peut être
l'action de l'AM vilude elle participe
d'abord au groupe d'appui technique
présidé par le directeur général de la
santé dont le rôle est d'évaluer les
pratiques non conventionnelles à Visé
thérapeutiqu de dire celles qui sont
dangereuses c'est celles qui son sont
prometteuses nous aimons beaucoup ce
terme de prometteuse ce qui veut dire
d'abord qu'on n'est pas des scientistes
fermés à tout à toute nouveauté et
deuxièmement que nous nous plaçons aussi
dans l'hypothèse même si c'est parfois
très difficile qu'il faut pouvoir
évaluer le bénéfice attendu de ces
nouvelles méthodes à la demande donc de
la Mivilude le GAT ce fameux groupe
d'appuie technique va bientôt publier un
avis présentant les dangers parce que
nous avons eu quand même les bonnes
feuilles de cet avis de la méthode par
exemple excusez-moi de la biologie
totale des êtres vivants misise au point
par Claude Saba un des un des nombreux
disciples du fameux docteur Hur et de sa
nouvelle médecine germanique j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure et nous avons
simplement une seule demande c'est que
le rythme de travail du Gat au au sein
de la DGS de la Direction générale de la
santé doit s'accélérer j'y reviendrai
nous avons mené une action de
sensibilisation et d'information du
public face au risqu encouru je
soulligne à cet égard la récente
campagne de prévention en direction des
patients atteints de cancer conduite en
lien avec l'Institut National du Cancer
l'INC et qui consiste à les dépliant
nous avons dans les dossiers qui sont
distribués dans les hôpitaux dans les
centres de lutte antiancéreux et dans
les cabinets médicaux enfin bien
évidemment le Guide Santé et dérive
sectaire qui qui été fait avec la
plupart pratiquement la totalité des
professions réglementées des professions
médicales et paramédical réglementé et
qui est bien sûr à la disposition paru à
la Documentation française nous avons
renforcé c'est sans doute je dois dire
un petit coup de chapeau à mon
prédécesseur qui a pris cette affaire en
main et il y a eu un changement aussi au
sein je le disais de l'ordre des
médecins qui s'étaient rendu compte de
cette dérive et nous avons donc renforcé
nos liens avec les liens nos liens avec
les professionnel dans le domaine de la
santé avec des actions de
sensibilisation des praticiens l'échange
d'information et la diffusion des bonnes
pratiques de ce point de vue l'ordre des
médecins est aujourd'hui très actif y
compris à non seulement pour les faux au
médecin pour exercice illégal de la
médecine je peux y rajouter l'Ordre des
pharmaciens avec l'exercice illégal de
la pharmacie qui est moins fréquent mais
on retrouve beaucoup d'appareillag
médicaments de pseudo médicament mais
également avec une action plus résolue
qu'à une époque vis-à-vis des médecins
diplômé qui
dévie enfin nous multiplions les actions
de formation des agents publics et des
professionnels des secteur concernés
pour améliorer le décryptage des
situations de notre pôle santé donne
ainsi des formations à l'École des
hautes études de la santé publique à
Rennes comme il donne d'ailleurs des
études des des des formations aux écoles
de la police de la gendarmerie auou près
des inspecteurs du travail des personnel
de la protection de l'enfance et nous
avons eu la chance depuis un an je crois
depuis l'an dernier d'avoir un diplôme
emprise secteire et processus de
vulnérabilité à l'Université de Paris
Saint René Descartes et nous voulons
absolument euh que cela est s'aime il y
a pas que les gourous qui devaient
s'aimer il faut aussi que notre travail
puisse s'aimer à travers le territoire
enfin bien sûr nous jouons un rôle de
coordination et de l'action préventive
et répressive des pouvoirs publics
souvent avecl des associations de
victimes sur lequel nous appuyons
beaucoup rien que dans le domaine de la
santé nous offons une petite statistique
que nous tenons à votre disposition nous
nous avons procédé depuis le début de
l'année 2012 à 12 dinonciation au
procureur de la République à 42
transmissions agence régional de santé
pour les sensibiliser sur des des
pratiques anormales de praticien de la
santé 60 signalements à des conseils de
l'ordre pour demander une l'ouvert d'une
enquête sur le comportement d'un
praticien ou dénoncer un exercice
illégal he toujours les deux les deux
branches 14 césines des directions
régionales de répression des fraudes au
sujet de produit ou d'appareil présenté
comme une vertu curative et sujet à
caution enfin nous avons répondu à plus
de 400 particuliers qui nous
interrogeaient sur des pratiques ou des
praticiens à risque nous avons un
certain nombre d'exemples à votre
disposition qui sont un bon
échantillonnage de ce qui nous arrive
quotidiennement enfin toutes les
semaines nous avons plusieurs
demandes ma fille est allée chez un
thérapeute au cours au bout d'un certain
temps il lui a demandé de s'allonger de
se déshabiller enfin nous avons je vous
assure que la lecture de ces
signalements évidemment nous sommes nous
nous demandons évidemment nous signalons
et il y a une vérification laisse quand
même rêveur sur cette emprise et ce
cette diffusion donc c'est une
préoccupation majeure pour pour pour
nous et je vous voudrais simplement vous
dire que trois exemples comment ça
fonctionne mise en œuvre et diffusion
d'une myiade de pratiques à risque
formation à ses pratiques par des
pseudothérapeutes et enfin infiltration
du système de santé par du mouvement à
caractère secteur je vais pas m'étendre
étant donné le temps qui passe monsieur
le Président sur les pratiques mais je
vous rappelle que dans les travaux
préparatoires au Sénat de la 2004 de la
loi de santé publique ont citit déjà
près de 400 méthodes je crains qu'il y
en ait nettement plus aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs on ne peut pas les compter
une méthode disparaît un autre praticien
invente une nouvelle méthode mais disons
que c'est de l'ordre de plusieurs
centaines de méthodes dont évidemment
l'évaluation est totalement impossible
il y a aucune validation scientifique
des méthodes sont
psychologisantes et il y a quelque chose
de très étonnant c'est le succès que
remporte un certain nombre de méthode
sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas de maladie
au sens vrai du terme pas de germe on
connaît ça depuis l'époque pastorienne
pas de microbe pas de virus pas
d'accident pas d'environnement c'est un
dérèglement p psychologique qui vous
amène à la maladie c'est un peu le alors
ça peut d'ailleurs être un une histoire
qui s'est produit à plusieurs
générations on a comme ça ce qui
s'appelle la psychogénéalogie qui est
très contestée dans le milieu des
psychologues alors qu'est-ce qu'on
propose à un malade atteint de cancer
une psychothérapie mais pas n'importe
quelle psychothérapie je vais revenir
très rapidement mais surtout d'arrêter
la chimiothérapie de renoncer à se faire
opérer c'est un peu le problème du
docteur amer enfin la théorie la
nouvelle médecine germanique docteur
amer
qui je dirais il a maintenant pas loin
de 80 ans mais depuis une trentaine
d'années et inspiré bon nombre d'écoles
de suivants et de thérapeutes donc je
vous donne un exemple très vite il n'y a
pas de facteurs génétiques et
environnementaux à l'origine de la
maladie par exemple la culpabilité des
fumeurs qui peut amener le cancer du du
poumon dont on sait que c'est le cancer
du fumeur plutôt c'est la culpabilité
plutôt que l'ingestion du tabac je veux
dire que c'est quand même quelque chose
de nouveau ainsi une méthode naturelle
de soin largement fondé sur des des
capacités libérées d'autoguérison du
malade à condition que ninterfère pas
dans ce processus les traitement
conventionnel le simple fait d'aller
voir un médecin conventionnel font en
l'air évidemment le traitement du
docteur amer et explique son échec alors
bien évidemment après une phase où il a
pu se répandre il est aujourd'hui
beaucoup sur internet j'ai pas le temps
malheureusement euh de de vous détailler
un certain nombre d'exemples de jeunes
femmes qui se sont prétendu guéris après
qu'on leur a expliqué que leur cancer
utérus cétait évidemment lié à des
problèmes psychologiques alors
aujourd'hui le docteur Hammer est
installé en Norvège hors UE donc c'est
une petite ben il a beaucoup de
d'installations de nos frontières et il
est spécialisé dans le traitement des
enfants atteints du cancer mais si je
veux dire inquiétons-nous il y a tout un
réseau de améristes de nouvelle médecine
germanique avec une infirmière madame si
je la cite ancienne présidente de
l'association stop au cancer de de
Chambéry qui en dépit de sa condamnation
pénale continue à col porter à faire la
promotion de la méthode amer un chiffre
parce que c'est sans doute la plus
dangereuse d'une poignée de fidèle cette
mouvance contait aujourd'hui entre 700
et 1000 praticiens dont les coordonnées
sont affichées sur les dizaines
d'annuaires dont pouvez vous référer au
plus important d'entre eux
annuerthérapeute.com c'est donc non
labellisé par le Conseil de l'Ordre
aucun conseil de l'Ordre
anuertherérapeute.com vous donnera la
clé à toutes ces médecines biz
qui compte il on y trouve pas moins de
137 praticiens de la biologie totale
alors parmi ces adeptes don je vous
citais le docteur Claude Saba qui a
lancé le concept de biologie totale des
êtres vivants et qui veut lui pour le
traitement des pathologies lourde
reprogrammer le patient et puis
évidemment toute école entraîne une
sous-école je ne citerai pas autre je ne
citerai pas autre chose que la
psychobiothérapie par le décottage
biologique chacun dénigrant bien sûr le
maître qui qui l'a formé euh tous ces
gens-là ont été à plusieurs reprises
condamnés par exemple am a été condamné
en 2004 à 3 années de prison par la cour
d'appel de chambberry pour escrorier
complicité de l'exercice illégal de la
médecine suite à la plainte déposée par
un homme dont l'épouse atteinte d'un
cancer du sein était décédé du fait du
refus de traitement éprouvé je crois que
nous avons mis dans les dossiers une
lettre que le docteur Hur entre
guillemets avait écrit au tribunal de
Chambéry pour défendre son élève la
fameuse infirmière de Chambéry la lettre
est totalement délirante elle pose quand
même un certain nombre de questions sur
le fait que des gens apparemment sensés
suivent ce ce genre d'enseignement et ce
genre de de praticien la lettre vaut son
qui est un délire où on apprend que il y
a un complot israélien pour répandre de
la morphine dans le monde entier et de
la chimiothérapie et que lui-même est
bien sûr une victime la plupart de ces
de ces pseudothérapeutes quand ils sont
condamnés sont d'abord victimes de
complot bien évidemment ça rejoint la la
complicité eu le les théories otiste
donc l'AM vilude avait alerté le
ministère le Premier ministre d'ailleurs
dans le rapport de 2003 sur la
dangérosité de la méthode àur alors pire
encore aujourd'hui nous avons euh
comment dire une exfiltration d'un
certain nombre de patients puisque en
France nous avons quand même un certain
nombre de de
de de gardefou si j'ose dire on envoie
des malades français pour des séjours de
2 semaines au Brésil euh où il y a des
médiums donc on alerte évidemment une
représentation diplomatique à l'étranger
surtout quand ce sont des gens très
fragiles et vulnérabl qui partent et par
exemple il s'agit d'un père d'un jeune
homme atteint d'un cancer du foie qui
arrêté tous ses traitements pour se
rendre aux Philippines au finin d'être
pris en charge par des chirurgiens en
main nues dont la tête de raison est un
certain Patrick
amoui évidemment le patient avait été
approché par un rabatteur l'ami d'unami
il est décédé depuis je pourrais en
citer énormément mais je veux vraiment
vous dire qu'on a là l'image d'un réseau
quasi mafieux avec une construction
pyramidale il y a une tête de réseau qui
est souvent maintenant réfugi une fois
fortune fête à l'étranger et qui agit
par l'intermédiaire de ses de ses
pseudopode et de ses disciples on a
quelque chose de plus pernicieux encore
qui est apparu depuis 5 ans quand je
parlais de la pratique c'est ce qu'on
appelle les faux souvenirs induits les
faux souvenir induit c'est quelque chose
qui nous vient d'outreatlantique et qui
touche des centaines de victimes des
thérapeutes alors là il s'agirait de
psychothérap toujours entre guillemets
euh on sont accusés d'user de leur
pouvoir de suggestion pour induire
plusurs techniques de manipulation
telles que Le Robur sous les thérapies
du rêve éviller de faux souvenirs
d'inceste chez leurs patients entraînant
des rupture très grave avec le milieu
familial tout d'un coup quelqu'un arrive
en disant et nous avons ces signalement
j'ai été victime de mon père de de mes
parents de mon grand-père dans mon
enfance les les faux souvenirs induits
alors ça repose sur quelque chose que je
vais pas rentrer dans un détail mais qui
est la première phrase de la
construction de Freud quand il a s'est
rendu compte qu'effectivement le
fantasme était souvent de cet ordre mais
Freud a tout de suite expliqué que ce
qu'on voyait dans un rêve ou dans le
reburse dans cette technique rêve
éveiller dirigé c'est une sorte
d'hypnose légère donc une sorte de rêve
dirigé Freud a très vite compris que
nous étions en face d'une construction
et qui avait donc toute toute la
psychanalyse est née du fait qu'on avait
donc il y avait ce cet échappatoire qui
consiste à dire mon père a abusé de moi
dans mon enfance c'était une des
première psychanalyse il ne comprenaent
pas il mais toutes les jeunes filles
n'ont pas été abusées par leur père
quand même lu raconter tout ça il s'est
rendu compte que c'était effectivement
un mécanisme qui était autre chose qui
avait une signification mais ces pseudo
manipulateurs ont parfaitement compris
ces ces charlatans et ses pseudo
psychanéistes onont parfaitement compris
et donc il font croire vraiment que ce
souvenir induit on induit le souvenir et
une réalité et donc avec toute la
cascade de drame de drames familiaux
mais derrière je le disais il y a
toujours les prétentions ex bitante j'ai
un exemple ici des prétentions
financières pendant 12 ans par
exemple c'est le tribunal cortion le
paru a à connaître en avril dernier pour
la première fois du cas d'un
pseudothérapeute pratiquant la technique
des faux souvenirs induits il était qu'
12 joint un an de prison avec surcis et
50000 € d'amende pour abus de faiblesse
il a bien sûr fait appel l'une des
plaignantes pendant 12 ans avait cru
être violé par son père pendant sa
petite enfance pour la sortir de son
malêtre accrochez-vous bien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pseudthérapeute
qui avait prescrit des stages intensifs
facturés j'ai fait vérifier le chiffre
je n'y croyais pas 40000 € la semaine ou
des séances de thérapie à 320 € de
l'heure on parle de des honoraires
médicaux là Mons le sénateur il y en a
qui s'embarrasse pas de négociation 320
€ de l'heure la jeune femme avocate de
formation veuillez me pardonner monsieur
le sénateur euh rond les liens avec sa
famille ses amis et applique à la lettre
les pratiques de son mentor jusqu'à
accepter d'avoir des relations sexuel
avec lui au-delà de l'argent il y a
toujours un bénéfice induit ce qu'on
appellerait les bénéfices
secondaires au deal elle aura débourser
238000 € avant de se rendre compte de la
manipulation mentale dont elle était la
victime une seconde victime ça paraît
invraisemblable a débourser elle 750000
€ en séance de thérapie pour se guérir
du traumatisme subi par le refoulement
de la tentative d'avortement qu'ait
commise la mère sur c'est une victime
masculine sur lui en introduisant des
les aiguilles à tricoter dans son
utérus donc la mère a voulu avorter ça a
dû rater et donc ça lui a coûté 750000 €
à lui voilà bon donc vous voyez que
c'est c'est c'est c'est ce ce pe
charlatan a donc été condamné voilà je
pour en citer bien d'autres n on est là
vraiment en présence d'énormément de
difficultés alors
évidemment nous avons également et là
nous sommes encore plus vigilants mais
nous sommes déjà mais il y a un public
encore plus vulnérable c'est les enfants
et plus particulièrement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les enfants en
en difficulté les enfants d'inadaptés
nous avons connaissez la querelle
monsieur monsieur le Président sur
l'autisme qui fait couler évidemment
beaucoup d'encre et je crois
que le désarroi ici c'est le désarroi
des familles et des parents et
l'insuffisance il faut le dire aussi
entre nous des de de de nombre
d'établissements que nous que nous
pouvons trouver dans ce pays donc un
certain nombre de de mouvements
sectaires s'engouffrent et promettent
euh euh un certain n de charlatan
sautoproclame thérapeute spécialis des
troubles de l'enfant nous avons un un
signalement que nous avons là
extrêmement grave sur une un institut un
IME je crois monsieur kalalfaoui un IME
où nous aurions ce type de de méthode je
veux pas y revenir plus longuement mais
voyez que l'actualité nous al c'est là
nous sommes très angoissés et nous
avertissons bien évidemment
euh les les les pouvoirs publics et en
particulier les autorit sanitaire et
sociale sur le fait que ces enfants sont
encore plus vulnérables que d'autres et
que il faut absolument et que les
parents sont souvent eux-mêmes très très
en difficulté là-dessus donc le secteur
de le deuxème secteur c'est évidemment
le bien-être j'y revenais c'est devenu
la porte d'entrée pour les thérapeutes
qui grâce à un discours apaisant des
méthodes commerciales agressives
parviennent à attirer de nombreux
patients à exercer sur eux une véritable
emprise mental qui leur font accepter
des pseudotraitements à des prix
prohibitifs alors on a là des centres de
bienêtre des centres de
de de réadaptation ou alors par exemple
on a je le cite très rapidement parce
que il vous permettra de de sourire un
ancien médecin rad vie par le Conseil
national Radi àe par le conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins qui en 99 pour
charlatanisme et commerce de la médecine
et qui a a néanmoins réussi à créer un
centre de bien-être en Vendé alors ça
s'appelle la crisealide vous voyez la la
la c'est très joli on la le papillon on
sort de de son cocon c'est un centre de
bien-être de ressourcement de remise en
forme qui s'adresse aux patients c'est
là que ça commence à nous angoisser en
cours de traitement lourd pour une
maladie chronique invalidante il y est
proposé des soins à la carte d'ailleurs
la carte est extrêmement coûteuse et on
peut y expérimenter contre espè sonante
et triébuchante ce qui est très injuste
à mon sens un jeûne à la carte vous
payez pour ne pas manger et on y a une
méthode extraordinaire la chromothérapie
qui est un outil thérapeutique c'est
dans le travail avec les couleurs qui
permet de personnaliser la relation d'
en agissant sur tous les plans au
travers de la technique de le CIS
enveloppe consciente intelligente et
sensible il est également proposer des
curs de 3 à 5 jours d'harmonisation et
de de détoxination avec lavement du
colon excusez-moi mais c'est tout à fait
dans le programme thérapeutique et on
propose aussi un nettoyage du foie avec
lavement toujours ces Molières et
absorption du sulfate de magnésium bon
ce qui est peut-être pas le plus le plus
grave mais en même temps je trouve que
c'est très cher payé pour C traitement
un peu barbare voilà et je vous passe
sur les cristaux les bols tibétains le
nettoyage de de l'URA enveloppe
énergétique et donc dans un
environnement chaleureux euh on va avoir
euh l'obli des souffrances du passé et
on se sentira tout neuf dans un corps
allégé voilà
alors euh nous avons réussi à empêcher
Monsieur Bourdin de se voir reconnaître
le le titre de psychothérapeute et nous
nous avons saisi le parquet des sables
de lonne pour le risque d'exercice
illégal de la médecine mais j'avoue
qu'un centre de bien-être qui fait
ceexercice illégal de la médecine est
peut-être plus compliqué à caractériser
qu'on qu'on l'imagine je passerai sur
les méthodes par massage ou à position
des mains vous avez vu la floraison
d'institut de massage certaines sont
très dangereuses on associe le massage
Sappel reéqui avec la méditation le
massage tuit Nua alors je vous le donne
aussi tout à l'heure je donne des
honoraires une séance de rquis c'est
facturé 130 € quand je dis facturé c'est
sans facture bien évidemment des
massages fininua qui permet de de
finalement de de prévenir et de soigner
toutes les maladies mais quand je dis
toutes je vais vous les citer les
troubles cutanés musculosqueltique
neurologique digestif respiratoire
génitaux hormonaux certains certaines
infections certains problèmes émotifs
bon voilà
donc alors là on a plutôt de et on
travaille très très bien avec le conseil
de l'ordre des kinésiérap
de l'exercice illégal de la profession
de massur kinésithérapeute qui nous a
alerté à plusieurs reprises sur quelque
chose qui d'ailleurs ressemble à la
kinésithérapie du point de vue de la
sonorité par la kinésiologie qui était
fondée en 1960 aux États-Unis et que
certains kinésithérapeut toujours le
même problème des diplômés qui partent
dans la marginalité
emploi je vous rappelle tout de même que
c'est les de ces adeptes ont quand même
mis en avant la dimension hygiéniste et
qui est devenu un dogme une affaire
jugée en juin 2005 par la Cour d'assise
de quimpère illustre ce constat je pense
que vous en rappelez des parents jeunes
parents un peu bon un peu perdu au nom
de conception idéologique inhérente à la
pratique de la kinésiologie et aux lois
biologique du docteur amer on le
retrouve toujours là le grand
inspirateur avait adopté pour eux-mêmes
bon et leurs enfants le régime
végétalien dans leorqu d'une
alimentation purifiée c'est une
alimentation carencée en protéines
animal et en vitamin et leur extrême
défiance à l'égard un monde médical jugé
à priori dangereux avait fini par causer
la mort de leur bébé allaité depuis sa
naissance il était déjà plus un bébé je
crois était au-delà du du stade de bébé
en état de malnutrition majeure comme
l'ont montré les services de pédiatrie
ancienne et chronique c'est ce qu' a
démontré l'expert médical auprès du
Tribunal c'est une affaire extrêmement
triste parce que nous avions des parents
qui étaient des parents aimants mais qui
sont étai totalement perdu et ont
continuait malgré les mises en garde et
le refus aussi de voir des médecins je
dire conventionnel excusez-moi de de de
de soigner leur enfant autrement et donc
cet enfant est mort dans un état de
dénutrition plus
récemment nous avons demandé à la
préfecture de charante maritime et à
l'ARS de de mettre bon ordre un centre
où des médecins qui une ancienne
clinique donc il avait des cabinets
médicaux installés c'était installé avec
des kinésiologue en en violation des
dispositions de l'article L
6323-1 du code de la santé publique qui
régit les centres de santé ils avaient
appelé ça centes de santé voilà et puis
certaines ARS ont plus que d'autres une
sensibilité sur cette question des
dérives sectaire dans le champ de la
santé je pense à la RS de Corse par
exemple qui suite un signalement
effectué par la mission sur les
agissements d'un couple de psecho
pseudothérapeute a saisi le procureur de
la République alors je dois dire ici à
votre commission d'enquête mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que nous avons
du point de vue des pouvoirs publics si
j'ose dire une écoute différente encier
voilà du point de vue de la santé nous
pourrions faire mieux je le dis vraiment
vous le savez une circulaire du 23
juillet 2010 relative au renforcement de
la lutte contre la maltraitance des
personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées au développement de la
biraitance établissements et services
sociaux et médicaux sociaux relevant de
la compétence de la RS prévoit
expressément la désignation dans chaque
agence dans chaque agence de régionale
de santé d'un référent dérive sectaire
malgré les demandes répétées au
ministère de la Santé la milun n'a
jamais obtenu la liste nominative de
référent et je crains qu'elle ne soit
très courte je crains qu'elle ne soit
très courte je pense évidemment en
reparler mais j'aimerais bien avoir
votre aide là-dessus au ministère de la
Santé alors cette absence de réaction de
la part des pouvoirs publics est perçu
par les charlatans de la santé comme une
sorte d'autorisation tacite une certaine
molesse de manipuler donc du coup don
permet de manipuler physiquement
éventuellement bon nom de nos
concitoyens je ne serais pas complet si
je ne citais pas la F thérapie qui
elle-même a été aussi dénoncée par très
violemment d'ailleurs et la réunion
avait lieu au Sénat au début septembre
par le Conseil national de l'Ordre des
Masseurs kinésithérapeute qui a dit que
la
fasthérapie en séance plinière ne
reconnaissait pas puisque cette méthode
de kinésithérapie puisque insuffisamment
approuvée et potentiellement illusoire
je passe très rapidement mais là aussi
c'est pour vous détendre sur les
méthodes par absorption de produits
alors vous savez qu'on peut tout donner
à ces malheureux c'est coûte souvent
fort cher nous avons trouvé de l'huile
essentielle de lin bon euh une cure de
jus de légumes de 42 jours comme cure
antiancer un médecin démissionnaire
parce que ça aussi on précède
l'exclusion en démissionnant des
médecins pour échapper aux sanctions lui
propose de soigner le cancer par un
traitement à base de jus de citron et
enfin nous avons un médecin italien qui
a fait fortune sans doute en prescrivant
dans le un traitement anticancéreux à
base de bicarbonate de soude ajoute que
tout étant un bon à prendre nous avons
une sorte de je le mets bien sûr entre
guillemets une sorte de méthode tuperoir
avec un une entreprise japonaise nommée
niken qui depuis
1973 vend des produits dans le domaine
de la santé pour une société plus saine
des finances saines surtout pour la pour
l'entreprise et qui sont sur le marché
du bien-être pour un air et une eau plus
pure et un bon sommeil et on vend des
filtres antibactériens au bracelets en
titane et des crèmes de
alors je vous lis quand même en une
seconde il y a un appareil qui s'appelle
le Power Mag qui est présenté par ces
concepteurs comme un appareil permettant
j'ouvre les guillemets de suppléer à
l'influence magnétique réduite de la
terre dans le but d'aider à la
restauration de l'état naturel auquel
les les humains se sont adaptés je n'ai
pas toujours bien saisi de ce qui se dit
parce que c'est une autre
caractéristique plus le langage est
confus plus évidemment le danger est
grand
euh mais et c'est son le danger est
grand quand c'est au dépend de thérapie
conventionnelle enfin dernier point il
se développe beaucoup on en a beaucoup
parlé dans on en a un peu parl dans
certains journaux sous des méthodes
d'hygiénisme alimentaire qu' on toujours
existé certaines sont parfaitement
respectables comme le
végétarisme qui qui est pratiqué par des
millions de des centaines de millions de
personnes de par le monde mais là on on
assiste
vraiment en particulier pour les pour
les enfants en 99 les de l'hôpital
d'Avallon saisite la justice après le
décès au service des urgences d'un
enfant de 2 ans et demi en état
dénutrition la même histoire qu' qu'un
père des nutritions sévères ses parents
adeptes d'une communauté associative
créant en 89 dans le département de
Lyonne limitent les apports alimentaires
au fruits fromages produits laitiers à
l'eau certains éliminent même les
fromages et les produits laitiers à la
demande de la fondatrice conseillè en
assistante en assistance personnelle et
naturopathie et puis c'était présenté
comme une une deuxème amaman 6 tous n'en
meurent pas beaucoup vous le savez parce
que les protéines sont indispensables
même si elles ne viennent pas de de la
viande on est on est pas du tout dans le
dénonciation du
végétarisme mais quand des protéines
animales manquent et c'est ce qu'on voit
y compris dans les
pays
sousdéveloppé le le développement
psychomoteur des enfants est retardé
donc on le sait bien donc là aussi alors
plus récemment nous réapparaît mais il
vient tous les ans en France faire une
une propagande une conférence de PRAG
grande une respirianiste qui peut qui
est une dame australienne qui n'a plus
qui n'a plus mangé monsieur monsieur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années euh
elle ne mange plus rien elle se nourrit
de quoi d'une énergie diffuse dans l'air
dans l'eau la lumière les flUes sexuels
et les aliments crus manger et boire
sont des effets nocifs la nourriture est
une drogue et il n'est pas naturel
d'absorber des corps étrangers bien
c'est une dame australienne elle a été
filmé en train de manger par une caméra
cachée australienne elle a expliqué que
des ondes négatives la caméra l'avait
empêché de de poursuivre son son jeûne
nous sommes quand même extrêmement
attentifs par un symptô d'abord parce
que nous veillons à ce qu'il a aucun
mineur dans ces conférences et que aucun
enfant ne soit amener dans ces stages de
21 jours qui vous propose royalement
c'est un stage de préparation progressif
au jeunes qui vous propose royalement
contre espèces solante tribuchante de
boire quelques infusions pendant quand
même d'abord quelques jours ensuite
jusqu'au bout le le le 21 jours alors
j'ai l'URE de plaisenter mais il y a
quand même eu plusieurs morts euh en
particulier dans les pays voisins euh et
ce qui me frappe toujours d'ailleurs
c'est que on demande toujours beaucoup
d'argent pour ne pas manger il y a un
monsieur Buchinger qui demande 4300 à
6300 € pour vous entraîner au jeûes ce
qui fait quand même très cher le nonreas
donc on je et puis il y a bien sûr
l'instinctothérapie qui se termine en
crudothérapie c'est c'estàdire on mange
plus que des aliments crus là aussi un
certain nombre de de
de d'atteintte à la santé enfin je
terminerai dans cette exposé par quelque
chose de beaucoup plus grave sur lequel
nous travaillons beaucoup en particulier
avec nos représentations nos
représentations diplomatiques à
l'étranger c'est l'utilisation de
produits stupéfiants
fortement
hucinogène je vous cite en particulier
trois produits le datura l'iboga
laayuaska qui sont distribués de rit et
dans le cadre de veiller chamanique et
donc un dans les pays d'Amérique latine
et d'Amérique du Sud c'est extrêmement
grave parce que quand c'est fait par les
chaman je dis pas que c'est bien mais
c'est fait à toute petite dose ils ont
l'habitude depuis des centaines d'années
de faire cela et ça met les personnes en
trans mais ce que nous assistons
aujourd'hui c'est une espèce de tourisme
de tourisme de gens paumés il faut le
dire avec des failles qui partent là-bas
qui font ces expériences extrêmement
dangereuses hors tout contrôle si j'ose
dire médical ou ou famili al et puis on
les met aussi dans ce qui est appelé des
hutes de sudation c'est-à-dire des
espèces de sauna extrêmement violent où
le chaman
initiateur leur les fait travailler dans
dans une espèce de de sudation avec des
stupéfiants en plus donc on a eu
énormément de de de de signalement
là-dessus et on a recensé plusieurs cas
mortels dont l'un est particulièrement
traité par la milude puisque s'il
s'agissait d'une personnalité qui pour
la suite d'un accident j'allais temp du
travail mais quasiment est parti là-bas
pour essayer d'oublier tout cela et et
mort très malheureusement là-bas euh de
ce point de vue grâce au travail que
nous faisons avec les représentations
diplomatiques à l'étranger nous avons
obtenu de l'ambassade de France au Pérou
tout ça se passe au Pérou dans les pays
voisins un avis au voyageurs de passage
certains font ce voyage une espèce de de
tour opérateur organisé où il y a à la
fois de de un peu de tourisme et surtout
c'est ces expériences extrêm extrêmement
dangereuse c'est un marché je dois je
termine là-dessus avec où ces pratiques
nonentionnelles on n'est pas capable
évidemment de le de le chiffrer mais
pour nous monsieur kalalfaoui a commencé
essayer d'avoir un chiffrage c'est des
dizaines de millions d'euros
certainement et l'impression qu'il est
en constante progression
évidemmentoin de le dire tout ça est
délivré compris les appareils qui sont
les a vu dans l'université de la santé
de l'environnement que nous avons eu à
sain quelques quelques semaines il y a
des appareils qui sont vendu entre 5000
et 20000 € destinés à remagnétiser et
cetera des gens les les achètent tout ça
est vendu sans facture évidemment alors
bien évidemment je vous le disais euh
les formations pratiques à risque sont
extrêmement nombreuses puisque pour
étendre la méthode chacun forme contre
espè sonant et trébuchante un certain
nombre de d'adeptes qui eux-mêmes
deviennent les formateurs et puis nous
retrouvons euh euh dans et c'est dans le
domaine de la formation professionnelle
c'est pas l'objet de votre commission
d'enquête mais je voulais quand même le
dire rapidement on retrouve de
nombreuses structures juridiques
professionnels libéraux ou travailleurs
indépendants qui inscrivent leur
activité dans le cadre d'exercice par
exemple des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur libre ou dans
le champ de la formation professionnelle
continue particulièrement dans le
domaine de la santé alors c'est un peu
l'annexe pèse 20 % de nos signalements
mais c'est souvent avec des ponts et des
liens c'est ce qu'on pour appeler le
développement personnel on glisse
peut-être de l'organique au
psychologique au
psycho à l'adaptation à l'entreprise
j'ai vu hier monsieur delevoie qui
travaille avec la section là-dessus du
travail en particulier sur les risques
psychosociaux et il m'a demandé de de
venir exposer comment à partir de ce
qu'on appelle la prévention des risques
psychosociaux ou la détection des
risques psychosociaux on peut trouver un
certain nombre d'organismes de formation
qui qui qui lance le requy la
kinésiologie et on trouve ouve
évidemment des faux ordres
professionnels avec l'ordre des
biomagnétiseurs qui propose un certain
nombre de de formation dans alors ce
sont des entreprises publiques des
entreprises privées voire des appels
d'offre lancés par pour l'emploi pour
par exemple remonter sur assez rare
psychologiquement des groupes de
personnes en recherche d'emploi et on a
un certain nombre de de d'université
entre guillemets avec des maîtres de la
santé qui bien évidemment s'occupent
beaucoup trop de beaucoup trop près
notre goût des enfants de leur santé et
bien d'autres choses ailleurs
euh je je lis ici par exemple je parlais
de voyage à l'étranger une formation
d'un d'un individu qui avait
l'université de la relation qui
s'appelait maître de santé
qui une formation qui s'est déroulé en
Vendé avec aussi exfiltration Guatemala
au Maroc pourant des milliers d'euros
les stagiaires devenaient notamment
conseiller en pédagogie pérentale ou
régisseur d'un village de naissance où
les futurs par tout ça entre guillemets
bien évidemment seront accueillis en
paix et non dans une atmosphère
concentrationnaire médicale
concentrationnaire médicale voilà nous
avons évidemment signalé toutes ces
dérives nous estimons tout de même pour
conclure que nous avons 4000 offres sur
le marché de la santé sur un total de
60000 organismes de formation ce sont
des chiffres communiqués par le
ministère du Travail et parmi ces 4000
dans le marché de la santé beaucoup
devrai être examiné de plus près nous le
faisons mais nous sommes une petite
équipe comme je vous disais et nous
avons parfois la surprise de
s'apercevoir que les formateurs qui se
proposent ont quelques heures ou
quelques weekends de de formation
eux-mêmes alors que il faut pour un
médecin 10 ans pour un et pour un
psychiatre ou un psychologue clinicien
pas loin de 10 ans ou même plus voilà où
nous en sommes aujourd'hui nous
participons d'ailleurs à toutes les
instances du de de la formation des
instances pour essayer de de d'avoir un
un certain nombre de de pistes de donner
un certain nombre de pistes là-dessus
enfin je terminerai par citer trois
trois trois moyens d'infiltration je
l'ai dit les médecins des des Viant 3000
chiffres de 95 donc certainement plus
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'il y a une
ambiguïé le titre de docteur en médecine
est délivré par les facultés de médecine
c'est un titre universitaire on peut pas
vous l'enlever si vous faites n'importe
quoi le conseil de peut vous interdire
d'exercer la médecine mais il peut pas
vous dire vous nêtes plus docteur en
médecine donc c'est c'est et et puis en
plus certains malins parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont avoir de graves ennuis avec
le Conseil de l'Ordre enlèvent leur
titre ne s'appelle plus docteur je citre
pas le non mais vous savez tous qu'il a
un célèbre amamaigrisseur qui n'est plus
médecin depuis que le conseilur des
médecins a commencé à s'occuper de lui
donc il n'est plus médecin il n'est plus
que vendeur de livres et ça marche
peut-être mieux encore que son cabinet
de consultation euh l'introduction de
méthode à risque au sein de l'hôpital je
dois dire ici que nous avons affaire à
des professions dans le domaine de santé
et sanitaire et social qui sont des
professions difficiles des professions
en difficulté pression démographique
difficulté de recruter un certain nombre
de professionnels je pense que vous le
savez très bien et deuxièmement la
profession en elle-même est une
profession stressante on a besoin je
crois quand on est dans le sanitaire et
social quand on est dans un épad quand
on est infirmière quand on est euh dans
psychologue dans un hôpital nous avons
besoin ils ont besoin elles ont besoin
c'est une des professions fortement
féminisées également euh de temp de de
formation j'allais dire de de se mettre
un peu en retrait surtout quand on est
dans des services difficiles comme les
soins palliatifs la néonatologie et
cetera bon excusez-moi je suis un peu
long mais je crois que c'est très
compréhensible qu'on ait besoin de ces
séances de formation et je dois dire que
les les les dirigeants les managers de
ces structures comme on dit aujourd'hui
euh volontiers sont prêtent une oreille
attentif à ce qu'ils savent que c'est un
des éléments de de de fidélisation d'une
part et deuxièmement euh de au moment où
le le le les personnels ont besoin de
cela et ils savent que c'est très
important et donc nous attirons
régulièrement l'attention des
professionnels dirigeants que ce soit
des hôpitaux des instituts des des des
établissements médicaux sociaux sur le
fait d'être extrêmement attentif de ne
jamais hésiter à nous consulter quand
ils ont le moindre doute mais il nous
consultent pas toujours quand ils font
une offre de formation euh auprès des
personnels sanitaires et sociaux et de
ce point de vue nous avons parfois de
très mauvaises surprises euh d'autres en
plus que vous le savez dans ce pays je
crois par une espèce de pudeur nous ne
contrôlons enfin nous les diplômes ne
sont rarement contrôlés on vous demande
une photocopie rien de plus facile que
de photocopier de scanner un diplôme
aujourd'hui certains diplômes même sil
sont authentiques pas photocopiés sont
quand même des diplômes qui prêtent à
caution Université Libre université de
pays étranger avec lequel nous avons
aucune relation de de de j'allais dire
d'équivalence le ministère de la Santé
vérifie par un diplôme du docteur en
médecine de Roumanie on a beaucoup de
médecins roumains correspond bien à
quelque chose mais euh beaucoup sont
quand même sont quand même sujets à
caution donc c ces problèmes de
formation sont pour nous extrêmement
importants et de vérification des
diplômes enfin nous avons peut-être
d'une façon plus classique mais je
voudrais le citer euh monsieur le le
président connaît bien euh des des
attaques plus directes euh à l'intérieur
des des structures hospitalières nous
connaissons les comités de laison
hospitaliers des Témoins de Jéhova
qui veulent absolument rentrer dans le
fonctionnement de de l'hôpital depuis la
loi droit des malades de 2002
évidemment les on a une ouverture de
l'hôpital et une meilleure attention à
ce que veulent les malades moi je suis
évidemment nous cette loi est très très
intéressante mais certains s'engouffrent
là-dedans et puis nous avons la fameuse
Scientologie qui sous couvert de
Commission des Citoyens pour le droit de
l'homme pour les droits de l'homme la
CCDH fait le siège de tous les
psychiatres de tous les parlementaires
de tous les hôpitaux psychiatrique et
tous les malades et leur famille bien
sûr beaucoup sont aujourd'hui avertis de
qui est derrière la CCDH mais rien que
le terme a beaucoup produit à confusion
nous y avons vu beaucoup de de médecins
ou de parlementaires nous disant ah mais
vous avez donc j'ai été alerté par le
Comité des Citoyens pour les Droits de
l'Homme confondant cela avec la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme voire avec la Ligue
des droits de l'Homme les deux
organismes d'ailleurs on font paraître
des communiqués et sont et ont dépos
peinre pour une espèce de durpation de
de synonymie euh ou d'homonymie plus
exactement d'homonymie mais c'est vrai
que le mal est fait et on on travaille
beaucoup sur les internements psychiatri
qui vous l'avez remarqué sont toujours
abusifs bien évidemment voilà donc je
crois que nous avons nous avons repéré
aussi un collectif des médecins et des
citoyens contre les traitements
dégradants de la psychiatrie voilà au
terme de cet exposé que je sens trop
long mais nous voulions et je voulais
vous remercier aussi tout
particulièrement Monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs pour
nous avoir donné l'occasion de d'être un
peu les premiers auditionnés donc de
vous donner nous avons un certain nombre
de pistes de travail que je tiens à
votre disposition bien sûr de votre de
votre commission d'enquête parlementaire
il nous semble dans ce que j'ai dit je
peux vous les donner pour ne pas
allonger le l'exposé que un certain
nombre de pistes de travail de de
modifications législatives vous c'est
c'est c'est vous en vous le vous le
verrez sans doute vous-même au cours de
vos travaux et réglementaires pourrait
être porté parce que pour terminer
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs nous voyons que notre
législation qui est très forte en France
avecistance de la milut qui est un peu
unique je l'avais dit en Europe est
quand même mise en défaut par un certain
nombre de de de petit petites béances
par où s'engoufre ces milliers de
charlatans et notre souci des des
victimes potentielles ou réelles fait
que nous devons absolument nous aider
d'un armature réglement législative plus
plus plus importante mais aussi une
forte mobilisation des pouvoirs publics
et je sais que vous y contribuerez je
vous remercie de votre attention bien
écoutez merci c'était particulièrement
intéressant et je vais immédiatement
parce que le temps passe passer la
parole à notre rapporteur qui a un
nombre assez conséquent de questions à
vous
poser merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président de
l'amilude d'abord merci mer
pour la mesure de vos propos alors je
crois qu'il il est important en la
matière d'avoir une approche
mesurée le souci que nous avons eu nous
en déclenchant cette mission d'enquête
c'est d'être conforme à des principes
auxquels nous sommes très attachés à
partir d'ailleurs de la laïcité la
liberté de de conscience la liberté
d'expression la liberté de religion et
je vous remercie d'avoir aussi comme le
président bien ciblé quel était quels
étaient nos nos
objectifs nousons bien compris
aujourd'hui les les difficultés les et
les dangers contre lesquels il faut
lutter l'emprise mentale d'une personne
sur un autre la mise en danger de nombre
de nos concitoyens et puis ce qui va
avec et que vous avez très
complètement rappeler l'exploitation
financière qui est quand même beaucoup
au au cœur de ce
débat si nous avons souhaité
que l'action de la mission d'enquête
soit concentrée sur la question de la
santé c'est qu'il est
grave de ne pas soigner lorsqu'il y a
une maladie qui peut être soignée en
tout cas qui peut justifier un
traitement permettant aussi aux malades
de vraiment lutter contre la maladie et
puis il faut aussi penser au cas où des
comportements
déviants peuvent provoquer des maladies
ou des comportements à risque et pense
en particulier au domaine
psychologique vous avez par votre exposé
d'ailleurs répondu à une partie des
questions que nous souhaitions vous vous
poser je crois qu'il il y a une première
question qui était pas forcément prévue
mais moi qui m'a paraît
intéressante c'est que vous le savez il
y a il y a eu en 2006 une mission
d'enquête à l'Assemblée nationale avec
Monsieur fenec qui était président de la
mission d'enquête et comme
rapporteur député Wilk avec un certain
nombre de de constatations qui
concernaient le le domaine des enfants
dans ce rapport il était fait état et on
peut considérer d'ailleurs que c'est
quelque chose de d'important et de grave
que plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'enfants étaient concernés par ce
problème de de dérive secteire dans
le dans le domaine de la santé al
question c'est de savoir si depuis cette
mission d'enquête dans ce domaine là
puisque le notre est plus génal il
s'adresse pas que il ne concerne pas que
les enfants il y a eu des
évolutions je sais pas si vous voulez
répondre à
question oui
merciieur le le rapport que de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire de
l'Assemblée nationale que présidait
monsieur monsieur FEC s'appelait
l'enfance volée donc l'aspect sur la
santé était pour
important il était pas pas exclusive de
cette de cette commission d'enquête bon
quels étaient en fait les dangers que
nous avions vu pour les enfants et sans
doute que depuis 2006 il y a eu des
évolutions qui sont pas toutes
malheureusement dans le bon sens c'est
que plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'enfants autour de 40000 vivaient dans
des mouvements fermés des des des des
secte la plupart d'entre eux je le
dis je le dis ici pouressayant de me
rappeler de mémoire le le rapport de de
la commission d'enquête
parlementaire étant soumis je crois dans
des famille dit témoin de Jéhova au
risque au risque de de de ne pas être
soigné en particulier mais c'est quelque
chose qui est bien connu s'ils avaient
besoin de la médecine dite officielle et
plus encore de la chirurgie officielle
et de la transfusion sanguine vous savez
que aujourd'hui et cavant le rapport
d'ailleurs ce problème s'il est toujours
j jour présent peut être
résolu de façon très très simple puisque
les médecins ont le le droit le devoir
de soigner l'enfant sans tenir compte
l'enfant le mineur sans tenir compte de
de de de ce que souhait ou ne souhait
pas les les parents donc de ce point de
vue le problème est résolu alors on a
peut-être eu le enfin résolu pourrait
être résolu et il s'est sans doute
déplacé sur les majeurs aujourd'hui plus
que sur les enfants
voilà c'est bon en revanche ce alors il
existe bien d'autres groupes hein je
voudrais pas ici focaliser sur ce groupe
mais qui était le plus important
numériquement il existe bien d'autres
groupes je les ai cité où on met en
avant plutôt ce que je pourrais appeler
des des dérives hygiéniques de groupe
sectaire des dérives hygiéniques
alimentaires j'ai cité deux cas
particement dramatiques qui avait ému
l'opinion et qui avait conduit les
parents devant les tribunaux bien
d'autres qui sont parfois moins graves
je parlais de d'absence de développement
intellectuel existe et de ce point de
vue nous aimerions effectivement une
action plus forte des des des pouvoirs
publics dans le fond la santé d'un
enfant c'est aussi son éducation il n'y
a pas que que que le refus par exemple
des vaccinations de ce point de vue la
comment appelleon ça la navigation sur
le sur le net prenez le terme
vaccination vous ne verrez jamais enfin
il doit y avoir ce que la HAS appelle le
calendrier vaccinal qui doit être mais
il doit être consulté en 20e en 20e
position par rapport au 19 ou 50 ligu
antivaccinal puisque c'est comme ça que
les qu'ell s'appelle ou groupes
antivaccinaux qui qui fleurissent et où
on s'échange quasiment les adresses de
médecin entre guillemets parce que là
pour le coup c'est c'est quand même
extrêmement inquiétant qui ferait des
certificats de complaisance
euh de contreindication antiaccinal
alors malheureus heureusement enfin
heure malheureusement nous ne pouvons
pas les repérer puisqu'on évidemment sur
ces sites il est marqué appelle-moi tel
numéro je te donnerai l'adresse d'
médecin je peux pas le mettre sur
internet donc voilà nous avons
aujourd'hui t tous cel sur sur ces sur
ces sites et puis des par je sais bien
que ça on surf aussi sur une vague et
que il y a eu des accidents de
vaccination qui sont toujours portés en
exerg on ne présente jamais les milliers
d'enfants qui dit qui sont aujourd'hui
soignés ou qui ne sont pas malades parce
qu'ils ont été vaccinés je rappelle que
dans les quelques communautés très
fermées je pense en particulier à
certaines villes des Pays-Bas où la
vaccination est très mal vue c'est là
qu'on trouve encore les foyers de
polyomélite infantile en Europe bon
voilà donc les derniers foyers sont là
donc c'est quand même tout à fait tout à
fait étonnant voilà donc nous avons à la
fois une des enfants qui sont mal
éduqués mal éduqués de ce point de vue
nous avions une discussion ce matin avec
des inspecteurs généraux un inspecteur
général de l'Éducation nationale sur ces
ces écoles à domicile
ces écoles de fête qu'on voudrait voir
transformer au minimum en école hor
contrat parce qu'il y a quand même un
meilleur contrôle de l'éducation
nationale j'avoue que c'est extrêmement
difficile et que nous avons un certain
nombre de communautés fermées où des
enfants et ça on si on prend la
définition l' MS il n'y a pas que la
santé physique mais aussi la santé
psychologique qui qui est et puis qui
n'ont pas toutes les chances si on
reprend la Convention des droits de
l'enfant je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
toutes les chances dans leur vie voilà
sur sur la et la situation ne me semble
pas pour pour ma part être en une grande
voie d'amélioration même si notre équipe
euh incite vraiment à regarder ça de
près depuis 2006 je crée en particulier
une désinffection vaccinale qui était
constaté par le ministère et le DGF euh
très très très très récemment qui
d'ailleurs ne concerne pas que les
enfants puisqueon sait que par exemple
la vaccination antigripale pour adultes
qui vient de commencer est beaucoup
moins suivie depuis qu quelques années
donc il y a certainement quelque chose à
faire de ce point de
vue merci vous avez en partie répondu
une question qu'on souhaitait vous vous
poser sur la différenciation entre
charlatanisme et secte parce que c'est
c'est il est évident que ça justifie
quelques explications si vous pourriiez
nous donner votre avis là-dessus sur la
différenciation et où commence la menace
se TER dans le domaine de la santé
oui c'est tout la difficultés merci
monsieur le sénateur de me poser cette
question et et c'est toute la
difficulté c'est c'est comme l'ABU de
faiblesse quelque part j'ai toujours je
dis toujours un plombier vient un faux
plombier un vrai plombier vient chez
votre grand chez votre grand-mère et
répare pour 2600 € ce qui valait 5 € à
changer un joint parce que il a essayé
un habit de faiblesse on a tous ça dans
dans j'allais dire
bon c'est pas une secte c'est un habit
de faiblesse et donc nous avons la même
chose dans le dans le domaine de la
santé pour nous les les caractéristiques
encore une fois nous interdisons même
indépendamment de nos jugements
personnels que nous pouvons avoir de de
jauger puisque nous appuyons le GAT le
fameux
groupe de d'évaluation thérapeutiques
nouvelles au ministère de la Santé la la
validité de ces méthodes mais par contre
nous diffusons largement quand un ordre
une autorité sanitaire a dit que c'était
ou inapproprié ou dangereux ou
totalement inactif bon n drit bon donc
pour répondre précisément à votre
question notre critère ce sont les 10
critères que nous que nous avons définis
au début de de de l'exposé et qui sont
un peu notre charte de base et bon vous
l'a dit tous les critères ne dont pas la
même valeur mais on retrouve quand même
de tro quatre critères l'emprise mentale
est est nécessaire vous allez et je
dirais même l'attitude de la victime
pour nous est monsieur le sénateur nous
indique les victimes ont beaucoup de de
difficultés à porter plainte ou à se
plaindre ou elles sont quand elles sont
dans dans les prise mentales pour
reprendre mon exemple un peu trivial la
vieille dame ou ses petits enfants qui
vont voir cette facture exorbitante de
réparation ben elle déposera pleinte ben
elle sera elle sera un peu confuse un
petit peu mais elle déposera pleinte
beaucoup plus facilement une victime de
de de de ce type d'affaire je citais cet
exemple ces exemples et cetera qui
peuvent se terminer très très mal pour
pour les personnes euh finalement c'est
une remise en cause personnelle très
profonde très profonde de leur elles ont
cru elles ont adhéré elles ont été sous
emprise qufis elles sont même sous
emprise des années après alors que le
phénomène sectaire si j'ose dire c'est
estompé il y a pas de barrière physique
il y a pas de prison rappelez-vous
l'affaire que la presse a beaucoup
décrite du fameux procès de montflanquin
c'est c'est extraordinaire j'allais dire
c'était emblématique les personnes
étaient en Angleterre le gourou était
loin mais il il continu à diriger ils
auraient pu s'enfuir à tout moment il
étaient pas souousclés à part un parce
qu'il était un peu particulier et un
petit peu un petit peu enfermé mais à
part une ou deux personnes mais le reste
de la famille adhérait librement à sa
propre servitude si j'ose dire et à son
absence de libre arbitre c'est tout à
fait alors c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel et j'ai nous avons beaucoup
comment dire espéré que le procè de
Monflanquin pouvait éclairer le le grand
public grâce aux médias et au aux
experts psychiatres et psychologues qui
sont venus et et bien sûr au R visitoire
et au plédoiries sur ce qu'est l'emprise
l'emprise mentale et et toute la
difficulté monsieur le sénateur et là
encore une fois les dérives
thérapeutique nous nous inquiète quand
elle commence à prendre un caractère
sectaire quand elle se répète quand elle
mais il peut y avoir des dérives
thérapeutiques qui ne sont pas sectair
bien évidemment on retrouve toujours la
captation d'argent les appareils vendus
très chers et cetera les poudes de parl
Pinpin elle nous inquiète quand elle
s'exprime dans un cadre
pseudohilosophique dans une conception
du monde de la mal maladie il y a là
quelque chose qui qui voilà que que
quelqu'un vous vous
vende par correspondance une poute de
parlin Pimpin pour parce que vous avez
des des rhumatismes comme ça peut nous
arriver et donc ça vous fera du bien ça
marche ça marche pas bon voilà vous avez
envoyer 30 € 50 € tout ça ne va pas bien
loin en revanche quand vous êtes dans
vraiment dans un phénomène on vous
explique que votre maladie est tout à
fait lié à autre chose que ce que vous
avez que ce qu'on vous dit ce que le
rumatologue ou le médecin généraliste
vous dit ça commence à nous inquiéter
que c'est et puis en plus moi j'ai ici
des termes auxquels personne ne peut
rien comprendre enfin je disais ce matin
c'est c'est pour je n'ai jamais vu
autant de spécialiste du quantique qn t
qe vous avez la physique quantique qui
est très l'air très compliquée et qui
n'est pas accessible au commun des des
des physiciens et là nous avons des
docteurs et des des médecins et des des
spécialistes et des biologistes en
biologie quantique en médecine quantique
en médecine et personne ne comprend à ce
ce ce jargon galimassia il enveloppe la
la personne qui se dit ah bah oui si
c'est je comprends rien c'est que ça
doit être ça voilà non mais c'est très
difficile de de de d'analyser nous
voyons beaucoup de victimes nous posons
on voit très peu de de à part dans les
tribunaux nous voyons très peu de
gourous de charlatan qui franchissent la
porte de la milune mais vous savez que
nous recevons des victimes nous les
orientons nous les
aidons avec parfois des difficultés
nousons beaucoup de familles aussi qui n
nous alertent mais à chaque fois nous
avons les mêmes questionnements comment
quelqu'un d'intelligent de d'avec une
profession avec de l'argent parce que
çaadresse toujours à des gens qui ont un
peu d'argent a-t-il pu se laisser
graduellement enfermer dans ce dans ce
genre
d'histoire vous avez évoqué un chiffre
qui selon vous ne diminue pas et et et
qui quand même interpelle c'est qu'il y
aurait plus de 3000 médecins déviant je
je fais attention en utilisant les
termes euh que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure comment expliquez-vous cela
puisque quand même de
tradition nos concitoyens et les malades
ont
confiance dans la dans les médecins en
général comment expliquez-vous ce nombre
aussi
considérable qui quand même devrait
devrait
inquiéter les ARS et les pouvoirs
publics et considérez-vous que comment
expliquez-vous cela et
comment concevez-vous l'action que doit
avoir que doivent avoir les pouvoirs
publics pour
éviter ces déviances
oui l'hypothèse des 3000 date de 1995
c'est le dernier chiffre c'est ce sont
des recensements difficiles c'est le
Conseil national de l'ORD des médecins
qui avait avancé que 3000 médecins au
moins aujourd'hui nous avons 240000
médecins même si on dit que le chiffre
est légèrement sous-estimé on voit
queaujourd'hui 1 à 2 % des médecins
auraient des pratiques déviantes alors
de ce point de vue comment
l'expliquer j'aimerais ne pouvoir
l'expliquer que par euh que par la PR
laattrait du du lucre si j'ose dire
l'esprit de lucre qui fait que c'est
toujours plus plus mais je crains qu'il
y ait bien d'autres mécanismes derrière
en particulier et là je je je sèche un
peu je dois vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur parce que si nous avons un peu
de rencontré beaucoup de victimes nous
rencontrons finalement très peu de de
nous appelons ça dans le jargon des
dérapeutes des donc des des médecins qui
qui dérapent dans leur pratique et nous
rencontrons également très très peu de
de gourous bon pour revenir au médecin
proprement dit ce qu'on remarque c'est
tout de
même je crois qu'il une espèce de dérive
lente de ces médecins peut-être
m'inspire de mon ma propreérience de de
médecin devant une certaine satisfaction
qui a toujours existé chez bon nombre de
médecins et c'est tout à leure honneur
par rapport à certaines limites des
traitements qui cherche qui qui
s'interroge et à partir de là qui
peuvent effectivement j'allais dire le
médecin y compris le médecin charlatanis
qu'on c'est pas uniquement par le
l'emprise le désir d'emprise ou le désir
de de gagner beaucoup d'argent très
vite commence à adhérer à des ce sont
des êtres humains comme les autres à des
théories qui leur semblent qui les
essayent de valider
voilà donc et encore une fois nous ne
sommes pas d'abord nous n'avons aucune
compétence hormis certains certains
d'entre nous sur ces sur ces questions
donc nousous interdisons absolument de
le faire en dehors des des des ordre des
ou des des institutions de la santé dans
ce pays et en même temps nous sommes
dans un esprit plutôt d'ouverture et de
mesure comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
rapporteur c'est-à-dire que nous pensons
pas que tout ce qui est nouveau est
nécessairement nous sommes pas les
académiques comme ceux qui condamnaient
le pastorisme au 19e siècle nous pensons
qui compris j'aime bien le terme de
prometteuse que certaines techniques
peuvent être prometteuses bien
évidemment euh moi j'ai j'ai souvenir de
de de de ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui des
par exemple ce qu'on appelle les
manipulations vertébrales qui faites par
des des le le le celui qui l'a
introduite en France vient de de décéder
c'est un médecin foragé mais qui avait
été à l'Hôtel Dieu le professeur megne a
formé une des générations d'élèves sur
un mais c'était extrêmement délicat et
il disait ne c'est pas du tout il y a
pas de don il y a pas de fluide il faut
savoir manipuler en particulier pour les
mots de dos qui sont euh un des fléau
d'aujourd'hui mais vous entre cette
démarche prudente et ouverte d'un d'un
grand professeur euh qui a formé pas mal
d'élèves à ses manipulations vertébrales
combien se sont engouffrés médecin ou
pas médecin et pour manipuler alors là
d'une façon n'importe comment euh et
finalement faire des dégâts terrible
parfois dans dans dans dans C dans cette
pathologie qui est qui est très
multiforme donc je crois que nous nous
si si si je n'ai pas d'explication clair
à donner à cette dérive elle existe elle
a toujours existé me semble-t-il et
notre souci c'est de justement pas
accabler ce qui est nouveau mais
d'accabler ce qui par ailleurs nous nous
nous nous retrouvons ce qui est un peu
ancien c'est-à-dire l'emprise la
captation financière et le désir de de
de de de monter sa propre petite école
et de former des gens très vite voilà on
a beaucoup de critères comme ça qui
montrre qu'il y a quand même une
différence entre le novateur et celui
qui va qui va qui va travailler j'ajoute
que tous ces médecins quand chaque fois
qu'il y a une juridiction ordinale ou
les tribunaux les tribunaux de de
l'ordre judiciaire dans ce pays sont
toujours victimes de complot hein de ils
sont sont méconnus ils sont incompris et
ce sont les les confrères qui les les
précipitent dans dans dans euh devant
les tribunaux alors que bon bien
évidemment le Conseil de l'Ordre le
Conseil national de sa section
disciplinaire est très attentive
d'ailleurs souvent euh un peu en de ça
de ce qu'on pouvait attendre he parce
qu'il y a une très grande prudence chez
eux
aussi parler de d'Internet comme outil
de communication euh voire de de
propagande pour des pratiques de santé
que on pourrait qualifier de porteuse de
dérives sectaires c'estd puis monsieur
mai peut-être et Monsieur calfi vont
compléter l'observation des S
l'utilisation si vous permettez comment
Internet est utilisé par ceux qui
souhaitent développer des des pratiques
inappropriées voire dangereuse et puis
comment faites-vous pour
veiller quelle est votre veille sur
Internet contre les dérives secteurs
dans le domaine de la santé qui vous
intéresse est-ce que vous avez
là-dessus des des
propositions à formuler pour améliorer
cette vigilance écoutez je vais
peut-être vous laisser la parole parce
que j'ai beaucoup parlé si vous voulez
bien sur notre vigilance sur internet
sur les dérives santé qui sont très
nombreuses une bouteille d'eau à côté au
cas
où c'est le meilleur des traitements oui
oui tout à
fait
allez-y monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement internet est aujourd'hui
un un vecteur de propagation fantastique
de de ces différentes méthodes il est
impossible aujourd'hui de pouvoir
mesurer le nombre de sites le nombre de
messages qui permettent la prolifération
de ces techniques de santé parce que
internet est un outil sur lequel il est
très difficile de pouvoir exercer un
contrôle donc je vaux peut-être vous
décevoir mais aujourd'hui la milude
n'exerce pas parce que elle n dans
l'incapacité matérielle de le faire de
veille Internet permanente sur ce qu'il
peut véhiculer sur sur le net n il y a
des services spécialisés c'est une des
propositions que vous trouverez dans le
document qu'on vous remettra à l'issue
de la séance il y a des services
spécialisés qui font actuellement
aujourd'hui une veille internet ce sont
les services de la gendarmerie de
surveillance de la cybercriminalité qui
à la demande de la Mission
interministérielle aujourd'hui font une
vaille internet de tous les messages
apocalyptiques à l'approche de la fin du
monde qui comme vous savez est attendu
pour le 21 décembre et notre proposition
est que ces services spécialisés que
nous formons à assure de façon
permanente une veille sur toutes les
propositions d'ordre thérapeutique qui
aujourd'hui prolifère sur internet j'ai
envie de dire faire une veille internet
pourquoi faire parce que c'est une chose
que de surveiller ce qui se passe sur le
net s'il n'y a pas de conséquence
pratique de l'observation qui en est
faite ça sert pas à grand-chose donc on
vous propose également que le résultat
de cette veille internet fasse l'objet
d'une information du public sur une
plateforme d'information par exemple
aujourd'hui le ministère de la Santé a
sur son site internet à une rubrique
d'information sur les pratiques
noncentionnelles vis thérapeutiques
dangereus et bien peut-être que le
résultat de cette veille internet des
pratiques qui sont diffusées et qui sont
les plus dangereuses pourrai faire
l'objet d'une information sur le site du
ministère de du ministère de de la santé
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui je je
le redis il est extrêmement difficile de
pouvoir mesurer le nombre de sites et le
nombre de pratiques qui sont diffusées
qui sont diffusé sur
Internet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur je voudrais
rajouter quelque chose aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut créer une méthode et
inventer son propre blog je dire pour
inventer enfin pour mettre en place un
blog il vous suffit de quelques minutes
en plus c'est gratuit donc c'est une
porte ouverte sur Internet et sur sur
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens donc c'est
une offre j'ai envie de dire commerciale
très très facile à à à proposer je vais
vous donner un exemple parce que il faut
savoir que ces gens-là certes utilisent
des des blogs créent des des sites
internet mais ils ont aussi des des
stratagèmes un exemple en préparant la
la campagne de sensibilisation des
malades atteints du cancer avec l'Inka
nous nous sommes rendus compte par
exemple que si vous allez sur le site de
l'Inca c'est WWE
ccer.fr et ben nous sommes tombés sur un
site internet qui mettait à la place du
e juste devant le E un L et donc il
remplacer eu cancer par le cancer et
donc du coup quand vous êtes quand vous
allez voir votre médecin qui vous dit
bon je suspecte quelque chose et cetera
la première chose c'est le premier
réflexe en général c'est d'aller sur
internet sur les forums de discussion de
santé et cetera et si vous tapez cancer
et que vous vous êtes renvoyé sur le ti
cancer vous allez arriver sur la méthode
ur et donc si si vous êtes en plus
désespéré euh bon voilà c'est dire c'est
c'est c'est vous voyez le le genre de de
stratagène bien sûr nous avons alerté
l'Inka qui a saisi le le le fournisseur
d'accès mais euh des exemples comme ça
on peut on peut vous en fournir beaucoup
beaucoup je voudrais juste terminer en
vous rappelant que la Haute Autorité de
Santé euh s'était saisi de de de la
question de d'Internet et et la santé en
2007 ils ont essayé de mettre en place
une certification qui s'appelle HON code
euh qui est fait enfin la certification
est faite par un établissement un
organisme privé malheureusement euh nous
avons eu à la mu de l'occasion à de
nombreuses reprises de constater que des
sites qui faisaient la promotion de
hamur mais pas seulement de hamur
disposaient du de la certification donc
c'est dire les limites de de l'exercice
je vous
remercie pour être plus complet ça veut
dire que il y a des failles et que il
doit être possible de faire quelque
chose vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
monsieur le Président d'écoute
différencié des pouvoirs publics mais
est-ce que dans ce domaine l'écoute est
suffisante merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour votre question me permet de
préciser parce que j'appelle écoutes
différencié euh depuis la loi HPST euh
les ARS qui ont repris euh euh une bonne
partie enfin qui ont repris la les
attributions des des DAS des dras se
doivent effectivement de veiller à
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
sont dans une phase d'organisation et je
ne voudrais pas du tout critiquer ce
qu'elles font mais il en reste pas moins
que elles sont parfois dans
dans différentes encore une fois
inégales dans leur appréciation de
l'exercice illégal de la médecine de le
du contrôle un certain nombre de de de
méthodes de de de thérapeutes alors il
est plus facile de contrôler euh un
médecin euh qui euh par le biais du
conseil de l'ordre ou de de de la des
confrères qui final euh qui euh
dériverait draprait évidemment dans le
jeallis dire dans le dans le dans le
feutré de la relation entre un
pseudothérapeute et son patient c'est
extrêmement délicat c'est extrêmement
délicat c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
euh le débat apporté depuis pratiquement
15 ans et il était très long à aboutir à
ce qu'on appelle un psycho thérapeute
parce que déjà à les époques ceux qui
dénonçaient le n'importe quoi dans dans
dans dans ces psychothérapies parlaient
du danger d'EM prise de sectes de de de
de mauvais traitement de de maltraitance
y compris des patients par définition
plus fragiles que d'autres voilà donc
nous nous estimons que si la DGS avec
qui nous travaillons a qui a peu de
moyens aussi pour pour
cela et l'affaire d'Internet qui est
telle qu'elle nous a expliqué est
finalement pour nous un un un bon
exemple du fait que les les les
charlatans et les et les gourous et les
pseudothérapeut ont toujours un temps
d'avance sur nous c'est-à-dire au moment
où nous essayons de mettre en place des
des méthodes pour essayer de de de de
comprendre ce que sont ces médecines
dites complémentaires de ce qu'elles
pourrait apporter ou ne pas apporter eux
sont déjà dans euh le sur internet par
exemple en train de de recruter alors le
recrutement se fait pas directement
c'est-à-dire que vous savez c'est en
plus le ce qu'on appelle le buz
c'està-dire un tel j'ai été soigné pour
ceci vous devriez voir tu devrais voir
un tel qui connaî qui une méthode
formidable laissons tomber tous ces
traitements et cetera et donc pour nous
ça fait partie de nos de nos défis de
nos défis nous nous sentons très très
peu armés et nous aimerions que les
autorités régionales de santé soient
parfois un tout petit peu plus à à à
notre écoute en sachant que encore une
fois c'est très variable d'une région à
l'autre d'un département à l'autre
puisque nous avons à faire aussi bien à
la RS alors j'ajoute en plus que la
régional l'ARS régionale et la
délégation territoriale départementale
sont parfois un tout petit peu les
articulations sont pas toujours
évidentes certaines euh la délégation
départementale même quand quand elle est
convoquée par le préfet puisque nous
avons normalement une ou deux séances
annuelles de groupe de travail
opérationnel avec les préfet et
l'ensemble des services de l'État nous
rendre compte que tous les services de
l'État sont pas départementalisés ou
n'ont pas les mêmes périmètres
d'intervention donc c'est par parfois un
tout petit peu complexe c'est notre
travail c'est aussi une mission de
coordination euh pour aider les préfets
à faire venir tout le monde et souvent
comme la RS n'est pas représenté qui on
a une direction territoriale donc
l'ancienne das on est toujours un petit
peu un tout petit peu
ennuyé merci de de votre réponse
d'ailleurs ça ça me permet de de de
rebondir sur sur une autre question euh
celui du du risque celle du risque
d'infiltration des rouages de l'État par
certaines sectes
euh par exemple avec les attributions de
marché public et de subvention ainsi que
des agréments divers vous en avez un peu
parlé notamment aux associations est-ce
que ce problème se pose dans le domaine
de la santé et si oui euh dans quel
terme mon cou peut-être vous répond ai
euh effectivement n nous constatons que
il y a de plus en plus de de de
tentatives et certaines malheureusement
aboutissent
d'infiltration de notre système de de
santé alors monsieur le Président de la
Mivilude avait parlé du la difficulté
des personnels soignant je veux dire par
exemple si vous prenez les personnels
qui sont en contact des des malades
atteints de de
cancer il y a souvent des on essaie de
mettre en place des des accompagnements
dans la gestion du stress la gestion du
quotidien et cetera c'est par ce moyen
notamment que s'engouffr les par cette
brèche que s'engouffrre les les
mouvements sectairire qui qui vont
délivrer des des formations dans le
champ de de la santé mais il y a aussi
un autre aspect que nous avons constaté
au sein de la de la Mivilude c'est
l'arrivée de for enfin de de modulle de
formation au sein même des instituts de
formation en soin infirmierers ça c'est
encore un autre phénomène qui nous
inquiète par exemple dans dans un ifs
dans la région paka nous avons constaté
l'introduction d'une d'un module de
formation sur la méthode Hur
ou sur la psychogénéalogie
euh bon voilà je dire des exemples comme
ça on en a je veux dire à répétition
malheureusement enfin il se répète
régulièrement mais c'est vrai que ce qui
ce qui manque aussi c'est la
sensibilisation des des je dire des des
équipes en place nous le faisons puisque
il y a une formation qui qui a commencé
à l'École des hautes études en santé
publique mais euh il enfin je veux dire
les mouvements sectaires avancent
toujours à visage
masqué ils ont pas quand ils arrivent
ils arrivent pour délivrer une formation
ils arrivent pour apporter du bien-être
au personnel ils arrivent voilà donc
toujours il part ils arrivent avec une
bonne intention et il est toujours très
très difficile de de déceler les les
manœuvres de de ces
mouvements
en ce qui concerne leis le profil type
de de l'adhérent à une secte bon ce
profil a pu évoluer dans le temps mais
est-ce qu'il y a des spécificités dans
le domaine de la
santé est-ce
que le terme adérant ce sont des
effectivement des gens entraînés dans
cette affaire et il y a bon si on parle
de effectivement de de personnes
majeures don qui qui ont on choisit un
moment ou un autre je met peut-être
choisi entre guillemets ce qu'on ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit c'est toujours la
faille il a il y a un moment j'ai
coutume de dire c'est c'était le
docteurin qui faait ça pour la rencontre
d'un jeune avec la avec la la drogue
c'est le le mauvais moment dans une vie
on rencontre la mauvaise personne alors
tout le monde ne peut ne tombe pas dans
cette affaire mais il y a des gens qui
parce qu'ils ont une faille parce qu'ils
ont une difficulté d'ordre psychologique
parce que un deuil une perte d'emploi
une rupture euh euh familial sont
vulnérables et je je suis toujours très
frappé par l'extraordinaire habilité euh
de de certains de ces gourous à sentir
ce moment à sentir ce moment et à
entraîner la personne à à faire un
retour sur soi-même à parler de ses
difficultés à parler de leur difficultés
et cetera donc le profil si je en devit
en définir un il est très variable c'est
tout de même un moment de fragilité et
ce que j'appellerais vraiment la
mauvaise rencontre
oui je alors des des fois c'est vrai que
les les mouvements secteur cible la
personne majeure mais euh l'autre point
d'entrée c'est aussi les enfants donc n
il y a il y a pas longtemps nous avons
euh on va dire grâce à la à la veille
internet même si le Secrétaire général a
eu raison de dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
véritaable vaille internet contenu de de
nos moyens nous sommes tombés sur un un
une une conférence qui était donnée par
une dame qui était venue des Pays-Bas et
qui pratiquait le chanling c'estàd la
communication avec un être supérieur une
entité de de de l'au-delà et qui
proposait aux parents d'enfants
autistes contre le paiement de 40 € la
séance donc c'était des conférences
publiques de de prendre la main de
l'enfant la tête de l'enfant entre ses
mains et par par un dialogue avec cette
entité de l'au-delà grâce au Ling
pouvait apporter un un réconfort et un
bien-être à l'enfant autiste donc quand
vous avez un enfant autiste si on vous
dit que dans le village d'un côté il y a
quelqu'un qui est susceptible d'apporter
un réconfort à votre enfant vous y allez
je dire vous vous vous posez pas la
question d rvees ou pas des
rivesité très très particulier bien
évidemment l'annonce d'une maladie grave
d'un traitement lourd d'une d'une
intervention chirurgicale importante
entraîne vraiment ce ce moment de
fragilité d'autant plus que on le sait
on le sait bien
aujourd'hui en particulier dans le
domaine de la de la cancérologie plus le
traitement est j'allais dire puissant
plus il est précoce euh plus le il sera
sans doute couronné de succès or c'est
effectivement une des grandes
difficultés qu'ont beaucoup
d'équipes d'oncologues et de
cancérologue c'est de c'est de de de
devoir à la fois pratiquement dans le
même moment dire à une personne vous
allez vous êtes très malade mais on va
pouvoir faire quelque chose mais il faut
faire ceci cela mais dans les très vite
voilà on a une place on est aujourd'hui
mercredi lundi vous rentrez à l'hôpital
et on vous fait ceci cela donc je je je
dois dire que si nous pouvions faire
autrement c'est sans doute pas facile on
éviterait peut-être des des d'extrêmes
fragilisation des gens sont totalement
bouleversés c'est c'est le problème de
de la réaction des soignants quand ils
ont en face un pati qui semble approché
par une secte ou tenté par des offres
thérapeutiques alternatives et là est-ce
qu'il y a suffisamment de de formation
des soignants et
d'information nous nous sommes
évidemment toujours disponibles pour
essayer de traiter ce difficile
problème évidemment on a on a on
travaille nous avons un comité
d'orientation un certain nombre de de
spécialistes psychiatrie psychologue on
va d'ailleurs c'est une annonce
à la suite d'une demande de essayer de
mieux travailler de mieux de mieux
réorienter si je notre comité
d'orientation pour faire en sorte que
ces questions là soient aussi abordé
c'est-à-dire comment faire pour ne
garder si j'ose dire c'est un peu comme
les familles quand un de leurs enfants
est parti dans une structure mais n'est
pas tout à fait parti il faut garder le
lien donc il faut à un certain moment je
n'ose pas dire adhérer aussi à ce que
font ce que fait la personne mais
essayer de le prendre et c'est vraiment
extrêmement difficile c'est extrêmement
difficile puisque le but de l'équipe ou
du médecin ou du chirurgien c'est quand
même que la personne adhère à son
traitement on peut ne pas ne pas on peut
avoir des réserves mais il faut quand
même adhérer au traitement or et c'est
d'autant plus aigu quand nous avons
affaire à une famille avec un enfant là
nous sommes vraiment dans des très très
grandes difficultés puisque toute
jeallais dire la plus plart des familles
nous préférons toujours ne pas infliger
si j'ose dire de souffrance ou de de ou
de long TR de traitement long et
difficile à un enfant donc c'est là que
ces charlatans et ses et ses gourous
commence à s'introduire en disant mais
il y a peut-être une autre façon de voir
les choses et donc pour nous c'est
vraiment une formation de ces de ces
professionnel devient quelque chose de
de très important et je je vous remercie
de de nous avoir suggérer parce que
effectivement il faut que nous ayons une
réflexion plus poussée sur cette
question comment faire pour garder ce
lien indispensable avec les patients
même quand ils ont envie on le comprend
parfois d'échapper à tout
cela B nous avons compris vous l'avez
dit qu'il y avait de quand même un
certain nombre pour pas dire de nombreux
décès qui découlent de ces pratiques et
de ces dérives qui a aussi la agvation
de certaines pathologies ou ou la
création de de certaines pathologies et
et cela est en lien et je crois qu'il
faut le faut le voir aussi avec la
dimension financière de ce phénomène de
des rives sectaires comment peut-on
évaluer les flux financiers liés à
l'influence de certaines sectes dans le
domaine de la santé
oui monsieur le rapporteur pardon vous
mettez le le doigt effectivement sur ce
qui fait mal euh aujourd'hui ce qui fait
euh vivre ces différents thérapeutes
c'est effectivement comme a dit le
président la pas du gain aujourd'hui euh
vous parlez tout à l'heure des coues
différencié de la part des des
ministères il y a peut-être un ministère
sur lequel il faudrait plus
particulièrement appuyer c'est le
ministère du Budget et les services
fiscaux de façon à à connaître ce que
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui comme
information
euh une idée précise des flux financier
qui circule puisque quand même ces
praticiens évidemment ne sont pas payés
par chèque ils ne sont pas payés par
carte bancaire par virement mais
uniquement en espèce et donc tout ça
représente une quantité phénoménale
qu'on peut évaluer à plusieurs millions
d'euros sans beaucoup se tromper sans
aucune trace évidemment avec des
phénomènes de défiscalisation de
détournement des circuits économiques
traditionnels et je pense que c'est
d'abord par une action sur les finances
euh que nous arriverons à mettre un
terme à à ces différentes à ces
différents phénomènes qui par certains
côtés ressemble beaucoup à une action
mafieuse c'est
évident j'aurais aussi une une question
monsieur le le président de la Mivilude
vous êtes un nouveau Président nous
savons qu'il y a des mises en cause dans
cet organisme a fait l'objet est-ce que
ça vous conduit à envisager la vigilance
différemment spécialement dans le
domaine de la
santé euh tous mes prédécesseurs ont été
euh à plusieurs
reprises mis en cause nous avons affaire
à des puissances si j'ose dire qui
appuyent parfois sur des des des
conseils juridique très très avisé des
des équipes très
importantes n'hésite jamais euh à nous
nous attaquer euh et euh comme nous
n'avons guerre d'immunité
euh ce n'est qu'une nous sommes en
général tous les présidents successifs
ont été mis en en examen un nombre de de
fois tel que moi qui n'ai pas encore été
mis en examen je me sens un tout petit
peu tout petit peu isolé dans cette
affaire hein voilà
euh donc j'attends avec non pas
impatient c'est jamais c'est jamais très
très très très sympathique mais en tout
cas la les premières les premières les
premières demandes en particulier
diffamation droit de rectification droit
de réponse de ce point de vue il y a
aussi quelques failles il faut le dire
le rapport quand nous le sortons le
rapport annuel de la M vilude remis au
Premier ministre bénéficie comme tous
les comme tous les les rapports
administratifs d'une d'uneune sorte
d'immunité on va dire enfin en tout cas
peut pas y droit de réponse si nous
mettons le même rapport en ligne sur
internet là le les droits de réponse
sont sont sont exigibles c'est un peu
étrange j'ai découvert ça récemment
monsieur masi peut expliquer ça mieux
mieux que moi mais enfin très peu de
gens ont remarqué y compris dans les
services de de l'État cette
extraordinaire différence qui fait que
la même chose peut être attaquée quand
elle est mise sur le net il les ont
parfaitement compris nos adversaires et
donc les demandes de rectification sont
extr exêment nombreuses dans la même
mesure en plus où ils sont extrêmement
attentifs à tout ce qui se
dit nous sommes parfois évidemment un
tout petit peu non pas inquiet mais je
dirais prudents y compris dans dans
l'expression publique d'un d'un certain
nombre de de de nos propres sentiments
bon nous nous nous marquons notre rôle
encore une fois c'est pas un rôle
d'investigation je nous ne pouvons que
alerter les les autorités des centralisé
déconcentrer l'État les les maires les
services de de renseignement ou comme ou
les procureurs de la République quand
nous nous estimons que la situation est
pour le
moins défavorable à une personne ou un
groupe de personne voilà bon maintenant
c'est vrai que je je veux ici profiter
pour rendre hommage à l'équipe que j'ai
trouvé qui s'est forgé au fil des années
qui sur la base du volontariat bien
évidemment venu de de d'horizon
professionnel de la fonction publique
différent a à cœur de de continuer ce ce
ce travail très très difficile très
délicat en tout cas qui parfois est est
très difficile je dirais du point de vue
humain parce que nous voyons des
situations quand monsieur Samir kel
faoui citait une perte de chance qui va
jusqu'à l'irrémédiable quand une famille
arrive en disant mon fils et cetera n'a
pas n'a pas souhaité ce ce faire soigner
parties je sais pas où faire un stage
thérapeutique de jus de de jus de fruit
à la place d'une d'une chimothérapie qui
aurait été certainement très lourde et
très et parfois dévastatrice qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on réponde qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on dise on est on on
est on est on est on est aussi anéanti
que ce que ces personnes surtout quand
quand le le l'irréparable a eu lieu donc
euh donc on essaie évidemment de
d'inciter les les autorités judiciaires
à poursuivre les les personnes qui ont
qui ont qui ont amené qui ont conduit à
cet acte et c'est là qu'on se rend
compte aussi de l'extraordinaire
plasticité et finesse et astuce de de de
ces de ces personnes qui franchissent la
frontière qui envoie des des des
ordonnances qui n'écrivent jamais
l'ordonnance eux-même mais qui la
dictent au téléphone et c'est les gens
qui euxmêm enfin tout ça il faut faut
voir on a affaire quand même à des à des
gens qui connaissent aussi bien et
parfois mieux que beaucoup d'entre nous
tout toutes les parcours ils peuvent
s'infiltrer et donc par exemple pour
convaincre quelqu'un d'un exercice
illégal la médecine il faudrait qu'il
écrive une pseudo une simil ordonnance
en disant voilà or ces gens-là ne les
écrivent pas il les suggèrent au
téléphone il disent prenez en note ce
que je vais vous dire et aller chercher
ceci cela à la pharmacie à partir de ce
moment-là il est extrêmement difficile
de de caractériser le le le le
délit monsieur le Président vous
précisez qu'aujourd'hui la milut fait
l'objet de qure procédure judiciire euh
devant des juges d'instruction ou en
instance de
euh
d'appel que évidemment ce ce risque
judiciaire
que que nous prenons à à sa juste valeur
entraîne de conséquences d'abord ça
entraîne une épé d'amocclé sur la part
des agents de la mission parce que la
responsabilité est
pénalement supporté c'està-dire que
personnellement personnellement supporté
c'est-àdire que c'est le président un
titre personnel qui sera condamné à des
peines d'amende ou des peines
d'emprisonnement avec surcil et que par
conséquent ça entraîne pratiquement un
phénomène d'autocensure je vous rassure
pour l'instant la Milu n'a jamais fait
l'objet d'autocensure euh et puis
surtout euh ça contribue à retarder
l'action des pouvoirs publics parce que
ces mouvements sectaires sont évidemment
très puissants très organisés ont des
avocats spécialisés et euh vont jusqu'au
bout de la procédure et nous avons une
procédure comme ça qui a duré 12 ans
concernant un ancien président qui vient
de s'achevé euh devant la Cour de
cassation et tout cela pose bien sûr la
question de l'immunité des membres de la
mission dans l'exercice de leur fonction
et notamment dans la rédaction du
rapport annuel remis au Premier ministre
et il faut souligner en cela l'action
notamment du sénateur enzen qui comme
vous savez pour le le compte de la
commission des lois lorsque nous l'avons
rencontré
avait envisager l'idée de permettre aux
membres de la mission de bénéficier
d'une telle immunité ce projet a été
adopté dans le projet de loi et dans la
loi Vars 24 dit de simplification du
droit économique adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale
euh sous la précédente mandature mais
qui a fait l'objet cet article d'une
censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel sur comme comme étant
cavaliier législatif ce qu'évidemment il
était euh notre idée serait bien
sûr un texte spécifique centralisé sur
les dérives sectaires qui reprendra un
certain nombre des propositions que que
votre commission pourrait formuler
intègre celle de l'immunité des membres
de la
mission très bien
juste excusez-moi monsieur rapporteur je
voudrais vous adresser mes excuses mais
je suis une victime j'ai pas le profil
pour être victime de secte mais je suis
victime de grève et j'avais donc prévu
nos éditions et cetera j'avais pris un
TGV pour
20h17 il se trouve que celui-là est
supprimé que je dois quand même être en
Avignon ce soir pour pour être demain à
différentes réunions donc j'ai un train
à 19h7 celui-là étant maintenu enfin
j'espère jusqu'au bout je vais devoir
vous quitter maintenant donc je vais
laisser la place à ma vice-présidente
madame prince et je voudrais lui lui
dire aussi que Monsieur vugrenard et
Madame de roche ont demandé à prendre la
parole après les questions de monsieur
le rapporteur car ils ont des questions
à poser excusez-moi et puis à bientôt
sûrement
merci
bien Madame la Présidente merci donc
c'est à moi qui chois l'honneur de
continuer cette rencontre j'ai pas de
train à prendre alors je vais donner la
parole à c'est Madame j'ai pas fini
c'est ah pardon pas fini je donnais la
parole très rapporteur merci Madame la
la présidente mais j'ai bientôt terminé
euh et d'ailleurs ce que vous venez de
dire m'amène à une question qui est en
lien
euh qu'est-ce qui vous semblerait
souhaitable au niveau du du renforcement
de l'arsenal
juridique destiné à lutter contre
l'influence des sectes dans le domaine
de la santé
oui je pense que indépendamment de ce
que nous avons évoqué
sur le personnel de la m vilude et ses
ses avanis ou ses ces aventures
judiciaires nous avons un de points qui
du point de vue législatif et
réglementaire enfin en tout cas
législatif pourrait nous nous
aider un des des points sur lequel nous
nous souhaitons évidemment revenir c'est
sur le fait que une interdiction
d'exercer par exemple pour un
médecin ayant gravement dérivé ou
dérapé n'est valable qu'en
France un moment où l'Union européenne
fait des réglementations très très
pointues sur un c très précise sur
beaucoup de sujet nous paraît
extraordinaire qu'un médecin par exemple
alors je sais bien que c'est pas la
législation nationale mais qu'un médecin
puisse continuer à exercer à quelques
kilomètres de la frontière ça peut
arriver dans des pays
voisins alors que il lui est interdit
d'exercer en France alors il y a pas de
remboursement mais jamais rembours de
demande de remboursement la sécurité
sociale dans ces caslà pour nous c'est
quelque chose qui nous semble qui nous
semble très très dommageable de la même
manière nous souhaiterions que l'on
précise bien un certain nombre
d'exercices illégaux qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui difficile à mettre en
évidence il y a certainement à revisiter
de ce point de vue les articles du code
de la santé publique monsieur mai vous
avez peut-être vous-même listé de
d'améliorations législatives qu'on
pourrait peut-être
oui merci monsieur le Président pour
pour compléter ce que vous venez de dire
on a peut-être dans le domaine juridique
trois types de propositions à à vous
soumettre d'abord celle qui viserait à
lutter contre la prolifération des
pratiques donc visi thérapeutique qui
présente un risque secte
et ce serait tout simplement d'interdire
ça paraît aussi bête que cela mais
aujourd'hui les pratiques thérapeutiques
qui présentent un risque ne sont pas
interdites par décret et notamment le
groupe d'appui technique dont il
faudrait sans doute renforcer les moyens
qui est placé auprès du directeur
générale de la santé qui depuis ses
création en 2009 n'a évalué que moins
d'une dizaine de pratiques et n'a émis
d'avis officiel et rendu public pour
moins de 5 de ces pratiques vous voyez
que ce rythme de travail par rapport aux
400 PNC qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
plusieurs centaines d'années ne
suffiront pas donc il faut sans doute
renforcer les moyens du Gat et permettre
au Gat puisque le GAT se fonde sur des
avis scientifiques pour prononcer la
dangerosité ou le caractère prometteur
d'une pratique et bien d'interdire par
décret celles qui sont dangereuses
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas fait il
faudrait sans doute prévoir une
modification législative qui permette
une telle
interdiction la deuxème proposition sur
ce ce premier groupe de de proposition
ce serait d'étendre les pouvoirs des ARS
aujourd'hui les les agences régionales
de santé peuvent contrôler uniquement
les profession de santé et les
profession du secteur médico-social mais
pas tous ces pseudothérapeutes et il y a
aujourd'hui il faut le savoir aucun
service de l'État qui est habilité à les
contrôler donc on se trouve dans une
situation ce sont des professions qui ne
sont pas réglementées qui ne sont donc
pas autocontrôlé par elles-même et
qu'aucun service de l'État ne contrôle
euh alors c'est quand même assez
aberrent que un tel vide juridique et un
tel vide de contrôle puisse perdurer
donc on pourrait proposer à ce que les
ARS qui sont quand même les services de
l'État qui interviennent dans le champ
de la santé puissent ne serait-ce que se
rendre dans un cabinet de
pseudothérapeute pour pouvoir contrôler
ce qu'ils font et pouvoir éventuellement
proposer
l'interdiction de leur activité troisème
type de proposition qu'on pourrait faire
c'est le contrôle de ce qu'on appelle
les centres de bien-être aujourd'hui de
la même façon que vous pouvez créer
comme l' dis le dit tout à l'heure
monsieur calfaoui une pratique de soins
vous pouvez créer un centre de bien-être
sans aucun diplôme et sans jeter
l'anathème sur cette activité il est
évident que ces centres de bien-être
sont aussi une porte d'entrée qui
permettent qui permet la proléifuration
de de ces méthodes charlatanesques
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
réglementation qui permet de surveiller
ou qui permettent de contrôler la
création d'un centre de bien-être voilà
un premier groupe de propositions
je résume bien sûr pour contrôler la
prolifération des pratiques non
conventionnelles à risque la deuxème
catégorie de proposition c'est pour
lutter contre la formation des pratiques
à risque et comme le disait le président
tout à l'heure il y a aujourd'hui la
prolifération d'université ou d'institut
de formation aujourd'hui il faut le
savoir le titre d'université est protégé
or les titres d'institut ne sont pas
protégés ça permet là aussi la ifération
de tout un tas d'organismes peu
scrupulés il faudrait renforcer la
protection du titre d'université
aujourd'hui on a un cas d'une affaire à
l'instruction l'université de la
relation dont le gourou est aujourd'hui
emprisonné pour avoir commis des
agressions sexuelles sur certains de ces
adeptes qui se rendaient dans son
université donc renforcer la protection
du titre de de l'université renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle des rectorats
sur toutes les formations faussement
diplô car aujourd'hui ce qui permet
d'attirer les chômeurs ou les personnes
en situation de recherche d'emploi ou de
reconversion professionnelle ce sont des
instituts de formation ou
des diplômes ou des formations
diplômante qui n'ont en fait de diplôme
que le titre mais qui ne débouche sur
aucun diplôme reconnu par l'État il faut
donc renforcer le contrôle rectorat sur
ce type d'enseignement et là aussi très
clairement donner l'information aux
étudiants de ce que le diplôme qui leur
sera délivré ne débouche absolument sur
aucune formation professionnelle euh
reconnu peut-être faudrait-il aussi tout
simplement parce qu'on est dans un
domaine très sensible interdire la
création de centres de formation dans le
domaine de la santé qui n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'un agrément ou euh d'un
enregistrement préalable aujourd'hui
vous savez n'importe qui peut créer un
centre de formation il c'est une simple
déclaration auprès des services
préfectoraux et encore c'est une
obligation que si vous voulez obtenir le
remboursement des frais de formation sur
le 1 % formation sinon c'est la totale
liberté peut-être que dans le domaine de
la santé faudrait-il qu'il y ait un
enregistrement préalable avec un
contrôles pour pouvoir créer un un un
centre de formation 3ème catégorie de
proposition c'est les phénomènes de de
lutte euh contre les c'est pardon la
lutte contre le phénomène d'infiltration
pour compléter ce que disait le
président tout à l'heure sur le titre de
médecin aujourd'hui lorsque un médecin
est radié par son ordre pour exercer sa
profession exercer son art il ne perd
pas d'e certaine façon c'est assez
normal son grade de médecin délivré par
l'université mais là aussi certains
praticiens un peu scrupuleux profite de
ce vide juridique et de l'ambiguïé et
continue à utiliser non pas le titre de
docteur X mais de X docteur en médecine
en visant le titre universitaire non pas
le le le le titre professionnel de
médecin peut-être faudrait-il proposer
que un médecin qui euh est radié de son
ordre ne puisse plus utiliser on ne
parle que de l'usage publiquement de son
titre de docteur délivré par la Faculté
le président l'a dit aussi il faudrait
harmoniser au niveau européen euh les
règles d'interdiction euh d'exercice
professionnel qui sont prononcé par un
un pays membre de façon à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de phénomène de tourisme euh au
sein de l'Union européenne et qu'un
médecin qui é été euh radié dans un pays
de l'Union ne puisse plus euh ne puisse
plus pardon exercer dans euh d'autres
d'autres pays euh de de l'Union euh
trème proposition qui nous semble très
importante tout à l'heure monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez parlé des
phénomènes d'infiltration on le sait
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de pratiques
non conventionnelles qui sont infiltrées
à l'hôpital et c'est une forme de
reconnaissance euh très souvent ce sont
des médecine complémentaire lorsqu'iles
entrent à l'hôpital mais progressivement
par l'emprise qui est exercée sur euh le
patient par le pseudopraticien ça
devient des des techniques alternatives
d'une certaine façon introduire à
l'hôpital ce type de pratique revient
leur donner une certaine légitimité et
bien peut-être faudrait-il que le GAT
puisque c'est une instance qui existe
donc le groupe d'appui technique placé
auprès du ministère de la Santé donne
son avis dans le casadre d'une procédure
d'urgence sur l'introduction de toute
pratique non conventionnelle au sein de
l'hôpital avant que celle-ci puisse être
mise en œuvre nous avons beaucoup
d'interrogations la mission de directeur
d'hôpital qui se sont rendus compte un
peu trop tard que certains protocoles de
soins qui pouvaient être dangereux avait
été introduit sans que toutes les
précautions préalables aent été mis en
œuvre
merci de question
monsieur s'il vous plaît merci madame la
présidente monsieur le
rapporteur j'étais
impatient pas seulement d'intervenir
impatient de
que nous abordions la question des du
début des solutions
quoi ce que vous nous avez dit Monsieur
Bisco était fort intéressant pour situer
le le cadre en quelque sorte et pour
apprendre pour ce qui me concerne
beaucoup plus que ce que je pouvais en
connaître avant le début de cette
réunion ainsi que votre collaborateur
mais je puis fa impatience que nous pour
que nous abordions les les les questions
d'efficacité pour résoudre cette
question majeure dans la période que que
nous traversons et donc j'ai un certain
nombre de questions à vous poser mais je
serai très bref compe tenu de du temps
qui qui nous reste euh vous avez
commencé à évoquer c'tait fort
intéressant l'arsenal juridique
complémentaire que N devrions mettre en
œuvre pour une plus grande efficacité
l'arsenal juridique existant est-il
suffisamment appliqué déjà existant
est-il suffisamment appliqué la justice
a-telle les moyens d'une bonne
application de ce que le législateur a
décidé ensuite nous av indiqué que les
correspondants régionaux de muinude euh
parfois était inconnu ou n'existait pas
je pense que ça serait intéressant en
fonction des régions des départements où
nous sommes de savoir quels sont les
correspondants de de minude déjà parce
qu'il arrive que nous soyons interpellés
que nous ayons connaissance de faits
troublants et donc c'est intéressant de
savoir là où il y en a de manière
également éventuellement interpeller la
puissance publique pour demander des
explications sur les raisons qui font
qu'il y en a pas dans dans d'autres dans
d'autres endroits et là encore pour
essayer d'être d'être concret et et
efficace comment se fait-il qu'il y a
3000 médecins qui sont semble-t-il un
peu en dehors des clous par rapport aux
dérives sectaires et que le Conseil de
l'Ordre ne soit pas intervenu pour
éviter cela c'est une incompréhension
alors ils sont peut-être intervenus je
sais pas mais comment est-il possible
que on puisse savoir le nombre de
médecins qui sont en dehors de clou
c'est l'expression que j'utilisais et
qu'on ne puisse pas euh faire quelque
chose pour que ça ne se reproduise plus
euh il me semble que comme en d'autres
temps dans d'autres pays on a pu
euh mettre hors d'état de nuire de de
grand banditisme par l'intermédiaire de
la fiscalité il me semble que là aussi
c'est sans doute un moyen efficace de
pouvoir opérer à condition que nous en
ayons bien entendu le la volonté enfin
dernière question vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer tout de suite d'un mot sur
l'harmonisation européenne effectivement
si un médecin n'est plus du conseil de
l'ORD etci il fait 20 km en l'ORS de la
frontière pour exerter ça pose entier le
le le problème connaissance de
aujourd'hui disposition européennes qui
seraient en cours qui serait qui qui
serait possible enfin et pour
terminer je pense que notre démocratie
souffre de ces faiblesses parfois et
souvent a a une distance entre les
responsables politiques et l'opinion
publique général c'est parce que souvent
nos textes ne sont pas forcément
compréhensibles ou d'évidences pour le
commun des morteles au début de vre
intervention monsieur buscoot nous avait
dit la loi fixe les bases effectivement
il faut que nous ayons un cadre pour que
nous-même nous ne dérivions pas la base
c'est prévention et répression des
dérives sectaires et non des sectes
comment expliquer que les sectes ont des
pratiques qui ne seraient pas sectaires
où il n'y aurait pas de dérive
sectairire voilà je pardonnez-moi cette
question de béocien mais c'est une
question que vous poserez n'importe quel
citoyen
en de avec la permission de Madame la la
présidente de de commencer par la
fin nous avons un passé dans notre dans
notre mission et nous avons au début je
crois dans la dans l'enthousiasme de nos
premiers pas d'ailleurs le titre de la
mission c'était mission interm de lutte
contre les
sectes s'appelait la MILS avant il y
avait l'Observatoire et ensuite la
première mission s'appelit la MILS or et
vous savez donc que nous avions la
mission avait sorti d'ailleurs une liste
de sa pour répondre monsieur le sénateur
à votre
question bon nous sommes rendus compte
finalement après pas mal de procès
d'ailleurs sur le caractère très peu
opérant de cette liste d'abord parce que
il suffit d'être dans la liste une part
soit pour aller en justice quand on
estime qu'on est des des des arguments
solides pour pour contester ou des rins
financièrement assez solide pour
poursuivre ça pendant des années
monsieur machine disait 12 ans 10
ans avant qu'une affaire ne soit jugée
mais surtout parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que ces groupements changeaient
de nom de nature de de forme juridique
très facilement et que on se heurtait
finalement un peu comme don kichot à des
à des moulins avant en essayant de
lutter contre tel ou tel que tel ou tel
groupement et puis je crois plus
profondément sur le sur le fond nous
avons lentement compris que euh la
difficulté n'était pas pour les nétait
était bien évidemment de protéger encore
une fois les personnes faibles fragiles
vulnérables futurs adeptes ou adhérents
de ces de ces mouvements bien évidemment
mais que nous ne pourrions pas jamais
caractériser dans le droit positif euh
telle organisation comme étant une secte
telle autre comme N pas d'autant plus
que bien évidemment certains secteurs de
l'opinion à juste titre d'ailleurs nous
reprocher une trop grande sévérité ou
une trop grande molesse dans c'est un
débat c'est un débat qu'est-ce qui fait
la secte c'est c'est un débat en
revanche nous avons et je le redit pu
définir un corpus doctrinal sur ce
qu'est la dérive sectaire que nous
pouvons et ce schéma nous pouvons le
j'allais dire le plaquer non pas le
plaquer mécaniquement mais le rapporter
y compris dans le domaine de la santé
qui était très peu présent je crois dans
la fin des années 90 nous avions
quelques dérives mais c'est c'est
vraiment le schéma de la de la dérive
aujourd'hui nous le voyons de la dérive
sectaire avec ses victimes nous le
voyons dans beaucoup de situations qui
peu ou prou se rattachent au domaine du
bien-être de la santé physique psychique
et du bien-être donc à partir de là
notre outil si vous voulez est devenu
bien meilleur nous ne caractérisons plus
la personne même si ou le le groupe même
si évidemment ment et ça nous avons un
service de documentation qui est déclaré
à l'acnil où nous voyons que les mêmes
personnes sous des noms différents après
même apparaît une condamnation
reviennent par une autre forme dans un
autre domaine du champ social c'est
quand même extraordinaire de constater
qu'un tel après avoir lancé un mouvement
pseudo spiritualiste et religieux
revient par le biais de la formation ou
de la santé 10 ans après après sêre
refit oublié ou avoir purgé une peine de
prisonir payé une forte amende donc on a
quand même ici une quelque chose qui est
plus du mécanisme que de l'organisation
elle-même et puis deuxièmement comme je
le disais d'entrée de jeu nous sommes
tout de même dans un pays de de liberté
de de la loi 1905 nous interdit à nous
administration publique ou donc le
service du Premier ministre admion
rattache au Premier ministre d'avoir une
quelconque opinion sur tel ou tel
mouvement sur tel ou tel sur tel ou tel
et je dirais que ce ce que vous
qualifiez monsieur sénateur de sect peut
n'avoir aucune dérive sectaire être un
groupe fermé être un groupe étrange
avoir une des des croyances qui qui
choquent le commun des mortels mais tant
que nous avons qui choque ou qui
interpelle je mais tant que nous avons
ni signalement ni mineur en danger ni
phénomène de captation financière ni
d'emprise c'est un nous nous ne pouvons
que je dirais que le garder dans nos
dans notre mémoire sans plus voilà donc
c'est c'est parfois difficile je je je
rajoute aussi que de de ce point de vue
indépendamment de de de cette difficulté
entre secte et dérive sectaire nous
sommes également soucieux de respecter
la la liberté de de de croyance de
religion et d'opinion y compris la
liberté d'aller devenir il n'est pas de
notre nature et de notre mission
d'empêcher quelqu'un d'aller voir tel ou
tel personne on nous on nous on nous
téléphone les journalistes les médias
des personnes mais pourquoi vous n'avez
pas interdit telle ou telle conférence
pourquoi au nom de quoi on interdirait
qu'une personne exprimer même pour
raconter ce qui nous semble
absurde voilà alors tant qu'on met pas
en cause la sécurité l'ordre publique et
cetera alors bien sûr dès que nous
trouvons quelque chose qui s'apparentit
nous signalons nous signalons au service
de ce qu'on appel les renseignements
généraux avant la réforme de 2009 nous
signalons en disant il faudrait parce
que c'est notre rôle c'est notre mission
il faudrait aller voir ce qui se passe
dans cette conférence c'est ça peut être
dangereux voyons s'il y a des mineur
voyons s'il y a des personnes fragiles
voyons si ce qu'on propose n'est pas de
de l'ordre de de la dérive sectaire j'ai
un autre exemple et je je passai ensuite
la parole à Monsieur Machi mais c'est
une bonne transition ce qu'on appelle
l'arsenal juridique est-il suffisant ou
pas nous avons une loi formidable qui ét
faite par un sénateur monsieur Abou et
une député madame Picard qui qui était
voté à l'unanimité dans les deux dans
les deux assemblées la loi Abou Picard
en 2001 Monsieur Machi a dit tout à
l'heure rapidement je crois 30 en 10 an
une fois fois que nous ayons qu'on a
informé formé les les magistrats 30
incriminations je crois en sur et
condamnation sur la une dizaine de
condamnations tout au plus au fondement
de la loi de dom1 ça nous étonne pas ça
nous a déçu bien sûr mais ça nous é pas
il y a rien de plus compliqué à définir
pour un pour un magistrat monsieur mai
ce que c'est que l'emprise mentale on
rentre dans le domaine de l'experti
psychologique la victime n'est pas
toujours compliante comme je vous disais
elle a honte elle est parfois plus mais
a parfois honte on se retrouve face j'ai
toujours l'intention de l'impression de
de de cette histoir d'isberg vous savez
quelque chose qui émerge et on se rend
pas compte de ce qui est
immergé je je le dis souvent la
comparaison avec les violence faite aux
femmes peut s'imposer il y a 20 ans ça
paraissait quand on donnait des chiffres
quand certain associations féministes
donnent des chiffres là-dessus on
pensait que c'était
totalement certain nombre de personnes
pensaient qu'on était totalement que
c'était des chiffres exagéré et puis on
s'est rendu compte pourquoi parce que on
a formé des des des d'abord des des gens
qui prenaient les plains dans les
commissariats de police dans les brigade
de gendarmerie donc des personnels qui
étaient là on a formé les travailleurs
sociaux on a formé également pourquoi ne
pas le dire aussi les magistrats à ces
questions j'ai j'ai vu le travail
magnifique qu'on fait un de procureurs
pour justement y compris dans leur
servicees en liaison avec les services
sanitaires et sociaux pour dire il y a
un véritable problème qui est bien plus
important que ce qu'on peut dceler
imaginez aujourd'hui bon avec toutes les
les je dirais tous les développements on
se rend compte que c'est un problème
majeur de notre vie de notre vie en
société et je crois que tout en ayant
sans doute pas la même le même nombre la
même importance numérique nous sommes en
présence du même type de
phénomène chaque fois que je je le dis
un petit peu off chaque fois que je me
présentetant présent de M je raconte ce
que ça mais monsieur finit tout ça
pourquoi vous racontez ça et finalement
il faut engager le débat comme vous le
faites monsieur le sénateur et je je
suis exactement dans le votre état
d'esprit en train de dire mais c'est
beaucoup plus sérieux qu'on imagine
prenez ces choses au sérieux peut-être
que certaines affaires qui finissent
devant les tribunaux avec une forte
raisonance médiatique euh peuvent nous
montrer qu'effectivement on peut perdre
la vie perdre l'argent perdre son
honneur quelque part ou ou en tout cas
une SA sa sa vie professionnelle et sa
vie familiale à rentrer dans ce domaine
de manipulation donc euh de ce point de
vue nous nous nous savons que c'est
extrêmement difficile d'ailleurs vous
monsieur bchine vous l'a pas dit tout à
l'heure parce que c'était dans le
domaine de la santé mais nous voulons
par exemple j'allis dire un petit peu
simplifier la loi bouicard en faisant
rentrer dans un certain nombre de
domaines où il est difficile à
caractériser l'emprise mentale
l'introduction de de circonstances
aggravantes qui vise le contexte de
suggestion psychologique dans laquelle
les victimes se trouvent placées euh en
particulier quand nous savons qu'il y a
dans dans dans un certain nombre
d'infractions qui sont les délit voir
des crimes d'ailleurs très grave et nous
savons même s'il difficile à
caractériser qu'il y a une emprise
secteire je pense par exemple au au viol
aux agression sexuelle aux escroqueries
au vol où très souvent nous avons là une
emprise sectaire qu'il est difficile de
caractériser et nous voudrions que ce
soit une circonstance aggravante dans
dans le code pénal monsieur bi sur
l'Arnel juridique est-il suffisant ou
pas délicate merci monsieur le Président
pour répondre dans l'Endre question de
de monsieur le sénateur effectivement le
le dispositif juridique existant n'est
n'est pas suffisamment appliqué pour
trois raisons de notre point de vue
d'abord parce que c'est vrai l'arsenal
juridique peut-être compliqué le
président vient de d'indiquer que la loi
boupicard est un des avec le délit
d'abus de faiblesse par suj son
psychologique est l'un des délit les
plus difficile à caractériser du code
pénal ce qui explique le nombre de
condamnations très faible et donc le
recours par les professionnels qu'ils
sot enquêteurs ouou magistrats à des
infractions qu'il connaissent bien comme
le le viol ou les agressions sexuels
l'abus de confiance l'escroquerie et est
ce qui nous pose aussi des questions euh
des problèmes en terme de de de
d'enquête statistique c'està-dire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement lorsque on
on arrive à une dizaine de condamnations
seulement pour le déit d'abut de
faiblesse les mouvements sectairs nous
disent mais où sont vos victimes où sont
vos condamnations tout ça c'est du flan
et donc l'idée effectivement euh que
nous pouvons formuler c'est que plutôt
de créer un délit autonome tel que celui
d'abus de faiblesse par sujestion
psychologique dans chaque infraction de
droit commun euh et bien soit créée une
circonstance aggravante du contexte
sectaire dans lequel les faits sont
constitués de façon à ce queil y ait un
code Natinf code Natinf c'est euh le
code qui que le ministère de la justice
donne à chaque infraction de façon à ce
que statistiquement on sache que euh tel
viol a été commis dans un contexte sect
sectaire tel vol a été commis dans un
contexte secteire aujourd'hui la
chanellererie est dans l'incapacité de
nous faire un recensement de ces
affaires et malheureusement on sait
qu'il y en a beaucoup puisque
aujourd'hui 50 euh affaires près d'une
centaine pardon près d'une centaine
d'affair affaires sont à l'instruction
ou en enquête préliminaire pour tout
type d'infraction qui révèle un contexte
sectaire donc ça c'est la première
raison qui explique que l'arsenal
législatif n'est pas suffisamment
appliqué c'est un dispositif qui est
quelquefois un peu un peu compliqué à
mettre en œuvre la deuxième raison c'est
que vous êtes en face de de mouvements
sectaires qui font preuve d'une
particulière ingéniosité et qui détourne
le dispositif législatif prenons la
réforme du titre de psychothérapeute en
2004 la loi qui illeurs seulement trouv
s'appliquer en 2010 par un décret et qui
a donc protégé le titre de et l'usage du
titre de de psychothérapeute
automatiquement qu'on fait les
mouvements sectaires mais ils se sont
plus appelés psychothérapeutes mais
naturopathes thérapeutes en matière de
santé enfin tout un tas d'autres
appellations qui font qu'il ne tombe pas
sous le coup de la loi et que voilà une
belle réforme qui a mis du temps à à
être appliqué mais qui est complètement
contourné par l'ingéniosité des
mouvements sectaires trème raison c'est
un petit peu
l'autocensure des services de contrôle
vous parlez monsieur le sénateur ce qui
me permettra de répondre par la même
occasion votre trème question sur
pourquoi 3000 médecins vous parlez de
l'action des conseils départementaux de
l'ordre des médecins nous avons beaucoup
renforcé notre partenariat avec le
Conseil national de l'Ordre avec les
conseils départementaux puisque on forme
chaque année les référents des r sectair
des conseils département au médecin
c'est une profession réglementée qui a
mis en place des référents sectaair mais
uss vous avez un un délite exercice
illégal de la médecine qui est très
compliqué à mettre en œuvre il faut un
exercice habituel de la médecine il faut
un acte médical et il faut l'absence de
diplôme tout ça c'est très compliqué à
mettre en œuvre et certains conseils
départementaux de l'ordre qui ont
poursuivi des confrère pour ce type
d'exercice ont eux-mêmees été condamnés
ensuite pour dénonciation calumnieuse ou
atteinte à la confraternité de la
profession parce que les éléments de
caractérisation des délit n'étaient pas
suffisamment rassemblés il y a eu une
relaxe pénale et donc le praticien
déviant s'est retourné ensuite contre
son confrère pour pouvoir obtenir gain
de cause tout cela évidemment n'est pas
facile et ce qui explique que le le le
dispositif aujourd'hui soit est
insuffisant soit est
détourné votre seconde question sur les
correspondant qui existe les
correspondant des Res sectire dans les
différentes administrations vous en avez
aujourd'hui dans les préfectures puisque
chaque directeur de
préfet est aujourd'hui le référent des
rve sectire de la mitude vous avez un
référent des rve sectur auprès de chaque
rctire
auprès de chaque procureur général et
auprès de chaque procureur près des
tribunaux de grande instance auprès des
directions interrégionale de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
auprès des directes direction
interrégionale de l'emploi de la
consommation et du travail et auprès des
groupements de gendarmerie vous avez
comme ça un maillage pas tous les
services publics mais vous voyez dans le
domaine de la justice dans le domaine de
l'éducation dans le domaine de de la
santé à ceci près queon l' cité tout à
l'heure nous ne disposons pas de la
liste des des référents des Rif
sectaires des ARS mais on essaie comme
ça de développer le nombre de de
correspondants et de les former parce
que le rôle évidemment celui d'une
coordination d'une sensibilisation de
leur profession au
décryptage des dérives sectaires et et
au signalement la question de la
fiscalité vous av tout à fait raison
d'insister dessus et je peux peut-être
vous donner un exemple assez parlant
nous venons d'apprendre que des services
de de renseignement travailler de
avec des services fiscaux sur ce qui
était devenu les anciens membres de
l'Endre du Temple
solaire et ces services fiscaux qui
voulait simplement savoir si les
exonérations de TVA étai
justifié par l'organisme de formation
est-ce que c'était de cela donc il
s'agissait à des pratiques
nonconentionnelles et thérapeutiques qui
avaient été créé par d'anciens membres
du Temple solaire était réel pour
pouvoir justifier donc d'une d'une
exonération de de TVA euh et bien l'AM
vilude n'était pas informé alors que
c'est ce que nous demandons depuis des
années que les services de renseignement
travail de concert avec les services
fiscaux de façon à ce que on repère la
résurgence d'anciens mouvement
apocalyptique dangereux et puis surtout
qu'on travaille sur euh les flux
financiers et les détournements des
circuits économiques traditionnels euh
aujourd'hui s'il y a effectivement bien
un ministère qu'il faut mobiliser sur la
question c'est celui euh celui du budget
l'harmonisation européenne monsieur le
sénateur je crois notre connaissance
qu'il n'existe aucun système
d'harmonisation et pour cause puisque la
France comme a dit le président tout à
l'heure est le seul pays d'Europe voir
du monde à avoir un système aussi
harmonisé avec une mission
interministérielle une loi spécifique et
puis un un système de subventionnement
des associations euh par contre nous
essayons de susciter cette harmonisation
nous avons commencé à le faire non pas
par le le B de la santé mais par le BIA
des mineurs en suscitant auprès de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe un un projet de résolution qui
ét adopté et qui explique aujourd'hui
c'est un député français monsieur
rudissal qui travaille sur la question
de l'influence des mouvements sectaires
auprès des mineurs de façon à aboutir à
la création d'un observatoire européen
des dérives sectaires touchant les
mineurs c'était pour nous la façon
d'intéresser nos partenaires européens à
cette question en les touchant par le
dénominateur commun qui était celui de
la protection des mineurs peut-être que
ce sera le début de la palot de laine
qui pourra permettre que nos partenaires
s'intéressent au thrif secteur aussi
dans le domaine de la
santé je vous remercie pour vos
explications et je pense madame deoch ça
va être très rapide madame la Présidente
puisque vous avez répondu à beaucoup de
questions par le biais du rapporteur ou
de notre collègue yannique vonard moi
j'avais par rapport à ces pratiques
nonconventionnelles vous nous avez bien
expliqué qu'ell devenaent des dérives
sectaires par rapport à des critères
définis par rapport à un acte simple de
de charlatan dans les critères que vous
aviez définis au début de votre exposé
il y a celui de la rupture avec
l'environnement familial autre qu'on ne
ressent pas forcément dans les pratiques
on est sur un effet une emprise mentale
même si ça induit forcément peut-être
une forme de rupture sur le coût
exorbitant demandé mais cette rupture
avec l'environnement n'est pas un
critère qui entre forcément en ligne de
compte dans le ou ou alors peut-être que
je me trompe par rapport à l'explication
donnée vous avez raison Madame madame la
sénatrice dans les critères de l'emprise
mentale est le numéro 1 bon les les les
demandes financières exorbitantes je
veux pas classer euh est aussi très
importante bon les la rupture avec le
milieu le milieu familial ou
professionnel ou social n'est pas
toujours là n'est pas toujours là il
n'est il ne devient évident que je dire
quand la personne rentre dans ce dans ce
phénomène mais et rentre de plus en plus
dans ce phénomène c'est mais d'abord
parce que je vais vous dire honnêtement
certaines familles dérivent tous
ensemble nous nous le savons euh alors
nous ce ce dont on se rend compte c'est
peut-être un peu anecdotique mais ça
fait partie aussi de notre quotidien
c'est que cela arrive en cela émerge en
particulier au moment où il y a une
rupture familiale un divorce en
particulier ou et à partir de ce
moment-là
euh dans les alors c'est très délicat
quand il a des enfants parce qu'il aussi
jeallais dire une espèce de de
d'instrumentalisation mais nous
apprenons tout d'un coup que un tel ou
une telle qui est parti était en plus
parti parce que il y avait l'influence
d'un d'un gourou d'un d'un d'un
charlatan et cetera bon dans le domaine
de la santé c'est peut-être moins
présent que dans d'autres domaines mais
nous le retrouvons parfois alors je je
disais c'est toujours très délicat parce
que des familles dérivent ensemble mais
parfois pour de bonnes raisons il y a un
enfant malade et donc l'un est plus
rétiscent l'autre un peu plus adhère
plus à cela et donc pour un traitement
et c'est très très compliqué c'est très
compliqué nousous encore une fois la M
vilu d' des rares services
interministériel en tout cas dépendant
du Premier ministre à recevoir du public
sur rendez-vous et parfois nous sommes
vraiment dans des situations très
complexes il faut euh je dirais une
certaine une certaine expérience pour se
rendre compte de vraiment ce qui ce qui
se peut passer j'ajoute que beaucoup de
ces personnes sont quand même très
perturbées très perturbées et donc pour
nous la difficulté est encore plus
grande que de savoir démeer de démeeler
ce qui est de l'ordre du du réel de ce
qui est de de l'ordre plus de de la
légué donc nous avons et en plus quand
une instance judiciaire est en cours
nous interdisons d'intervenir nous ne
sommes pas un service d'enquête nous ne
sommes pas nous sommes parfois consultés
consultés parce que nous avons de
l'expérience on dit qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce que c'est les
personnes qui sont parfois m en cause
vous les avez dans vos B c'est n ne
répondons qu'aux questions évidemment
d'un d'un magistrat d'un magistr
instructeur ou de ou de de dans le cas
une enquête préliminaire mais nous ne
sommes pas un service
d'enquête et je pense que les questions
sont
épuisées pour monsieur le
rapporteur merci beaucoup
madame voilà pour cette première
audition de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur les dérives secteur dans
le milieu hospitalier pour revoir cette
audition notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très belle journée à
tous